- Is it starting?
- It's face reveal, this
is the intro. (laughing)
- Face reveal, let's go!
(ambient music)
Hello and welcome to another episode
of "Trash Taste Podcast".
I'm your host for today, Gigguk,
and today, joining me are
my usual cohosts, the boys.
- Hello, we're the boys.
- Hello
- Boy one and boy two,
and today we have another special guest.
Do you want to introduce yourself?
- No, bye. (laughing)
(Gigguk laughing)
- We'll introduce you for you then.
This is our producer, Meilyne.
You probably heard her voice
or seen her passing
the camera a few times.
- Or seen us shouting at her.
- Seen us shouting at her, or whatever
but today's her face revealed.
This is what our producer looks like.
- She's a familiar face
in my videos, right?
Yeah, you're in-
- Really?
- Yeah, the Yaoi cafe,
you were like the heavy
breathing in the background.
(Gigguk and Meilyne laughing)
- I think you've been on
like all our channels, right?
At one point.
- I think so.
Like, the rental mom.
- Yeah, the rental mom one and yeah,
but like on "Trash Taste" at least,
this is the first time, I think.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, do you wanna
explain what your job is
and what you do and kinda why
you're on the podcast today?
- What's up with that,
why are you on here?
What are you doing?
- Free real estate, (laughing) but anyway,
yeah, I am Meilyne, I work at Book Walker.
You've probably seen that
on all of their videos,
they're free to use
all their coupon codes.
I don't have one, but yeah (laughing).
Anyways, yeah, so GeeXPlus
is a company under
Kadokawa and Book Walker.
And I started that within
Book Walker last year,
and yeah, now I work at...
I didn't even explain
that right. (laughing)
- Meilyne is a nervous mess.
- (laughing) The long
and the short of it is,
she's the reason we're all here now.
- Yeah, pretty much.
And she's the reason why
this show even exists.
- Yeah, exactly.
And the reason we invited her today
is because I thought
today we could talk about
some spicy industry news guys.
Yeah, so if you didn't know this,
a small indianime site called KissAnime
recently went out of business, "business"-
- Yeah, "business".
- That's at the time of
recording this though.
- As at the time of recording this
and yeah, I guess we just
wanted to talk about that.
- Talk about piracy
'cause you know, that always
goes well on the internet.
- Twitter has been a mess.
- Oh my God!
- When is Twitter not a mess?
- Oh God, I've seen so many
garbage takes about it.
Where do we even begin?
- Where do we even begin?
- We wanna explain what
a KissAnime even is.
- What is KissAnime?
- What is a KissAnime?
- I'll explain what KissAnime is.
Monkey brain here, to
explain things for you.
- Explain it like I'm five.
- KissAnime was probably
the most notorious
and well-known anime piracy
website for streaming
for a while.
- For a while, not anymore.
- Not anymore, but I'd say
at least three years ago,
it was definitely like the site.
And then you know, as somebody
who at one point you used it,
it definitely became a thing
of, "Oh we're using .ru now
instead of.com.
Okay, that's a little confusing."
- And then, suddenly it
acts like disposable bomb
or something.
- Yeah, you went to
like this, the pictures.
- The capture got so fucking complicated,
that I was like, I didn't
know how to navigate it.
And then it got to a point where
anywhere you click on the
website, you got an ad.
It was like trying to navigate minefield,
it's like, where can I
click without getting an ad?
- I was waiting for the capture
to turn into like Sulfurex.
It was trigonometry question. (laughing)
- It would ask for like
cat, cat and blue scape.
- Yeah (laughing)
(Gigguk laughing)
- It had essentially become a
second page of Google website,
It was like a minefield,
and it was definitely the most notorious
I'd say overall website
among the anime fandom,
and it recently closed its stores.
And people seemed very upset
about that for some reason,
as if there isn't like 500 other websites
that immediately pop up.
- One thing that really
confused me is that
why are people sad, I guess?
Who's still using KissAnime in 2020?
- Yeah, c'mon guys.
I hate the fact that I just joke tweeted
about being like "rip
kissanime, rip brokeweebs",
and it became my most popular tweet.
It's got like 90,000 likes,
I'm like, why? (laughing)
Who is like "#canrelate"?
It's my most popular tweet, and I hate it.
I fucking hate it.
'Cause I jokingly said
that in the sense of like,
who the fuck uses KissAnime in 2020?
And so many people were
like, "Relate queen,
I relate, rip brokeweebs."
- I don't understand Twitter.
- Yeah, I know. It's horrible.
- People were like, I don't
know if you guys got this,
were like atting me being like,
"You need to discuss this,
it's such big community news."
I was like why, what do you mean?
Pirate sites get shut down all the time,
and then another one pops up.
Like it's the reason we had like
every single country
extension ever of KissAnime,
is 'cause they move to
every fucking country
until they probably have
none left, I assumed.
- Yeah, I saw KissAnime
having a dot whatever,
in things that I've never even seen.
I was like "ru", I'm like,
that's Russia.
- That's Russia.
- You know, I don't wanna offend
the Russian fans of "Trash
Taste" and we have a Russian dem.
- Oh yeah, we have like a
large Russian demographic.
- Which is great, but I'm sorry,
I feel very uneasy when I
see that .ru in my browser.
I'm like, whoa.
- You know there's
something shady going on
if it's on .ru.
- Love Russia though, yeah, totally.
- They have other things though, right?
Not only KissAnime, it's
like KissManga, KissMovies-
- KissCartoon.
- There's a KissHentai as well, I think?
- Yeah, I think so.
- Yeah, there's actually a KissHentai.
- I remember, somehow
I got on to KissCartoon
and like "Family Guy"
was like the most popular
and I just sat there for a second.
I'm like people are pirating "Family Guy".
Like, you know YouTube exists, right?
All the episodes-
- Like, this shit is available
everywhere. (laughing)
- Do you remember that phase
where they were just like,
there was this streaming phase
where "Family Guy" episodes
would just be like streamed
on YouTube and it would just be like
24-hour "Family Guy" stream,
24-hour "Simpsons" stream.
- It was always the front page
of fucking YouTube as well.
- It's not official, is it?
- (Joey and Gigguk) No, no.
- It's not official
and yet like, every time I'd open YouTube,
there'd just be like 24 hours,
a 24/7 stream of "The Cleveland Show".
I'm like...
And there was like 700,000
people watching the stream.
I was just like, what?
But yeah, it's the same
thing that happened
with like Hentai Haven, right.
When Hentai Haven got shut down,
people were like,
"Where are we going to
watch our Hentai now?"
I'm like, I don't know, Google that shit.
There's literally 700 websites for it.
- I fell short out of the loop,
'cause I never used Hentai Haven,
and when everyone was losing their shit,
I was like, "But why don't
you just use the website
I'm using?"
- Why don't you just
use every other website-
- And everyone was like-
- A question to you Meilyne,
because you actually work in the industry.
So what is your opinion on KissAnime
and it's shutting down as a whole,
from like someone on the
other side of the wall.
- Someone who like, works
with the copyright holders.
- I don't really work
in like the anime side,
I work more on like the manga
and occasionally, we'll do
something with the anime.
So I can't really speak
for the anime industry.
- We've liked most of the discussion,
Twitter and like most of
the discussion on our side,
a lot of it is just speculation.
We don't actually know how much
piracy affects the industry,
you know what I mean?
I think it can be argued that no one-
- I don't think there's any like,
concrete stats right?
There isn't like...
'cause I don't think any
of these piracy sites
are making that shit public,
of like how much money
they're actually making.
- Of course not,
'cause they're making a disgusting
amount on all those ads.
- You can definitely guess.
- I mean, at one point,
KissAnime was like one of
the top 100 visited websites
on the internet, which is fucking insane.
Like imagine how much
money they were making
just from ad revenue
of being like the top.
- Probably worth it to
keep evading all the-
- Yeah, yeah.
- you know what I mean?
- Exactly.
I mean, they made a
disgusting amount of money
that they really shouldn't
have been making.
- Yeah, 'cause don't a lot of the...
Because obviously when you
watch something pirated,
it's not using a standard YouTube player
or like a normal...
It's using one of those really
sketchy third-party websites
that hosts anything.
I'm pretty sure those websites as well,
a lot of the ones they were using
would pay you to host files.
- Right, right.
- Like video files,
because they wanted their
player to become more universal.
So a lot of these were also...
KissAnime at the time,
again, I'm not sure,
but from what I understood,
they were getting ad revenue,
like a lot of it, I imagine,
'cause you've gone on that website
and you've got like, what, 10 fucking ads?
- Hot asian dating-
- (laughing) Hot singles in your area.
- It's like always fucking
Lois from "Family Guy"
being rammed, and it's like,
I'm just trying to watch anime,
what is this?
- And that'd be always like
these shitty hentai games
that would be advertised.
I think one time I was watching something
and just this advert of like Cunt Wars
or a game called that,
I'm just like, is this for real?
Is this for real right now?
I think that's a real game,
because that just stook out of my mind.
- To be fair, I want to play Cunt Wars
just from the fucking name of it.
- I love Rentokil, I'm joking. (laughing)
- Don't you accidentally
click on those ads sometimes,
and then once you click
it's like, boom, boom,
all these pop-up windows.
- Yeah, it's like "Boom, boom, boom,
sex free now in your area," like that.
So they were getting like
double-dipping ad revenue.
They were getting paid to host the files,
and they were...
Sorry, I leaned back, I
always fucking do that.
Okay, so, they were
getting like double ad rev
basically, right?
So, and then, you know, people on Twitter
which I disagree with, I think you can...
Say, okay, there is a need for piracy
in some extents, right?
But then there's people who're like,
"Boohoo KissAnime man",
it's just like, they're
doing the real hard work.
It's like, are you kidding me?
It's probably like four
dudes racking in millions,
but I wouldn't like feel
sorry for them, what the fuck?
- So, I didn't see the full story
of like how they got shut down.
- I assume they just got
shut down by some DMCA claim.
- Right, but at the same...
Because they've had their
thing shut down several times,
right?
Like they went from like kissanime.com
to like .net to like
.ru eventually, right?
And then when that happened,
there was also like, obviously not as big
because I don't think there
were articles about it,
but people were definitely making a fuss
of like, "Oh no, KissAnime is down."
And then two weeks later,
they're back with a new url.
So, that's what I just assumed
when I saw that article.
I was like, oh, they'll
be back in like two weeks.
- I think it's the first
time they've put in
like a message saying
like, yeah, it's over.
- On their discord, right?
- I think so, yeah.
- I don't even know
why they had a discord.
- Who the fuck is in
the KissAnime discord?
- Why would you need a discord? (laughing)
- It was like, I love KissAnime so much,
I'm going to join the discord.
- There's always that
argument that people present
where it's like, what
is it, Gabe Newell said,
like piracy is a service
problem or something?
- I think it's gone way past that now,
because the piracy is a
service problem argument
always gets brought up and it's just like,
it's a different situation
with the anime industry I feel.
- Games is a really different thing.
Have you ever tried to pirate a game?
Like that shit is annoying,
like straight up, just annoying.
- But one thing I find
unique to anime piracy,
and even hentai to the
same extent as well,
is that in no other industry do I see
a pirate service get the branding power
that it does in anime.
- It's true.
- If you want to pirate a movie,
or if you wanna pirate a game,
where'd you go for that?
You probably go to Google, right?
But there's no like, "Oh
yes, there's kiss gaming,
I go to kiss gaming every day,
I would die if kiss gaming...
Are you part of the kiss gaming discord?"
- I downloaded Cunt Wars
on kiss gaming. (laughing)
- But you don't see that
in any other industry.
And it's like, I don't know why
it is specifically to
like the anime and manga
and then like hentai circles
where piracy just has this branding power.
Where people will gather
behind this service
which is just like any
other pirate service,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, that's true.
Because I remember,
I think it was right before
Hentai Haven got shut down
as well,
I remember they messaged me being like,
"Hey do you wanna promote our merch line?"
And I'm like, "I'm not
promoting a merch line
for a fucking pirating website."
Like, I'm sorry.
That's like, if Pirate Bay was like,
"Bro, we've got like these-"
- They actually?
- I can say that because they gone,
but yeah, they fully did that.
And, I remember I messaged a few people
just being like, does this seem right?
I think I'm missing something here.
I don't think this is right.
(Gigguk laughing)
- You're not the only person,
but it wasn't Hentai Haven,
Oh really?
- It was KissAnime.
- They messaged you?
- Yeah, yeah.
So KissAnime were going
to open like a store,
they were going to open a store.
And they messaged me being like,
"Hey, do you wanna promote our store?"
And I was there sitting, are
these guys for real? (laughing)
What makes you think you're
gonna get away with this?
And they had like an entire store page
that they linked me to,
and obviously it was
like official products
that were being sold
unofficially, of course.
- Were they typing to you or
writing to you in clear English
or is it broken English?
- No, it was actually in clear English.
- Was it in Russian? (laughing)
- No, it was like a proper
store and everything,
and I'm just like, man,
the balls on these guys.
- The Hentai Haven store as well was like,
he had already even made
like a landing page for it.
And he was like, this is
the lineup for the stuff.
And it was like, t-shirts,
obviously it wasn't anything
too amazingly well-designed,
but you know it was just simple stuff,
like the Hentai Haven logo
on a t-shirt or something.
And I'm like, ah, no!
And then two weeks later,
yeah, I think it was maybe
like two or three weeks later,
they got like, that whole thing happened
where they got shut down, right?
- I wonder if it comes from disdain
from the major companies
more so than them,
'cause they don't actively brand anything.
They don't do anything.
They don't have like a hehe
funny Twitter account right?
Like KissAnime never did anything.
I think it's just because-
- It's all community driven.
- I think a lot of the community
just does not like the
big guys, which, whatever.
- They're easy to share too.
- Yeah, they are.
- If your friend doesn't have an account
and they're new to anime
and you're trying to get them to anime,
you'll link them to like a pirate site.
- And also it works in
every country, right?
A lot of the unofficial stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I do think there is a space for piracy.
I made an entire video on Fansubs
and how that was really really
important for the community
and how it helped it grow.
And I wanna make that argument,
that I do think there is a space
where piracy did very much did play a part
in helping anime grow, especially abroad.
But I think it has gotten to the point now
that anime, I don't know,
It doesn't have that same effect anymore
because anime is now big enough
where everyone knows anime.
So I think there's still
like a lot of countries
where that kinda need
piracy to help boost anime
to make this a truly global medium.
But places like the U.S and the UK
and, you know places where you
have a lot more accessibility
and the fandom is a bit bigger,
it's like that argument
doesn't hold as much water
as it did fucking 10 years
ago or something like that.
- I mean 10 years ago, I mean,
no, even further beyond that,
the whole Western community
came from piracy, right?
'Cause you had to get
like a bootleg, like VH...
Why, I say H like that.
- VHS.
- VHS tape, right?
You had to get a bootleg one,
it was all shared around.
It wasn't all piracy, but
obviously like you said,
it's growing out of that.
And I guess some people
wanna hold onto that
and argue that's how it should be.
- I think that's the biggest
problem though, right?
Is that a lot of the discussion
that revolves especially
around anime piracy
is like, both sides of the
argument is very very much
situated on both sides
of the spectrum, right?
It's like you either hard agree
that piracy in anime is bad,
or you hard disagree.
Like there's very rarely any people
who are kinda like, there's benefits,
but there's also demerits to it.
- I'm definitely someone who's
in the middle. (chuckling)
It's hard for me to get involved
in any discussion on Twitter.
Because if you say anything,
they either put you on
one side or the other.
You're either like hard into piracy
or you're like a fucking Crunchyroll
and Funimation or Book Walker
shit, right? (laughing)
- Filthy Book Walker shell.
- I work at Book Walker.
I know I probably shouldn't say this,
but I'm in between.
The only reason, I'm
technically in this industry
or I got interested was because
there were pirate sites.
- They got you into it, right?
- Yeah, and I got into it.
And now there's just so
many subtitles available,
so many platforms,
there's really no excuse,
but if you wanna see something
fast and in low quality
and maybe the translations are out
because it's stuck in Netflix, sure.
- One question I always had about,
on the Japanese side of things is that,
how aware are the Japanese companies
of all these pirate sites?
- Very aware.
- Are they very aware?
- Yeah, I've talked to...
- It feels very Japanese,
where like, "We don't care, I sleep.
Oh, you're pirating our anime? I'm woke."
- They care, they're
very strict, especially,
not talking about like websites,
but for example, YouTube.
- Yeah, we know.
- Feyus is not a thing
in Japan, unfortunately.
- When we've worked with sponsors,
if we want a show just to
get screenshot in anime,
if they're sponsoring it,
they'll bring that up.
Like, "Could you have brides
to show the screenshot?"
And I'm like, it doesn't matter.
If they have a problem...
'Cause I guess the YouTube mentality is,
if it's a problem, they'll
let us know, right?
We're all copywriters,
whatever, we'll fight it.
Or if it's really unfair
and I've just uploaded
the 10-minute "Family Guy"
or 24-hour "Family Guy" stream,
yeah, I probably shouldn't
be doing that, right?
But most of the time it's like,
if they have a problem they
can come and tell us, right?
I feel like they're very
much a risk-averse mindset
where it's like, just don't
ever allow that situation
to happen.
- Yeah, like on the Book
Walker side of things,
how much of an effect do
you guys see on piracy
on your side of things
and how do you go about
justifying that as well?
- That's a hard question.
- - That's a toughie.
- That's a loaded question,
that's a hella loaded question.
- I mean, if you don't have
an answer, that's fine.
- Yeah, I don't really
have like a huge answer.
Well, Book Walker's technically very new,
and despite it being around
for almost five years,
when a pirate site goes down,
we don't see that much of effect
because our users,
the people who have been
coming to our store every month
are the type of people who
want to support the industry.
So if people have been stealing for years
and they don't have money,
even if the site goes down,
they're not gonna come to our store.
That's like in the West,
but in Japan, there's this site called,
or used to be a site, you
probably know it Joey,
Manga Muda?
- Yeah, Manga Muda.
- When it went down, there
was a huge increase in sales.
- Manga Muda was basically
like the KissManga of Japan.
It was one of the biggest
manga pirating site,
and that got like properly shut down.
The founders were like straight up charged
and went to jail and everything.
- Oh, wow.
'Cause I assume the thing happened
to a big Western app recently
which was manga rock,
that got shot down.
- They didn't really shut down.
- Did they not?
- They like pivoted and shut it.
They shut down the app in many ways,
and then were like, "Hey,
we have other stuff,
check it out."
- They pulled a .ru basically. (laughing)
- But after they shut down,
did you see any change at all
or increase in traffic or
sales or anything on your side?
- Not so much I would say.
Because they also, I don't
know if I should share this,
Book Walkers more popular
for light novel readers,
and usually pirate sites have manga.
So when they wanna read something
like, I don't know, longer or whatever
and they wanna pirate it,
they're going to stick
to other pirate sites.
- Is there any noticeable difference
between the spending habits of Westerners
and Japanese on manga?
Anything that you're allowed to tell us?
- Because I think the general stereotype
is that the Western audience
is very fucking stingy.
- Yes, extremely stingy.
- I remember it, 'cause I
think I had this mindset
of I'm not paying for any media.
Like when I was like 13,
'cause I grew up with just
like pirating everything.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And then I think once you take that step
of paying for media, I
think you don't go back.
'Cause you're like, whoa,
that was really easy.
- That's the thing I always feel piracy-
(Gigguk laughing)
That's why I've always said,
piracy isn't exactly a bad thing,
because I feel it's just a stepping stone
towards getting into the actual fandom.
And then once you're mature enough
and you've made your own
money and what not...
- Yeah, I do think most of the time,
I'm not saying it all the time,
it's normally the younger
ones who are diehard piracy
and it's like, yeah, okay,
that normally comes from
having no income at all-
- Yeah.
- Maybe your parents give
you like 10 bucks a month
or something, I don't know.
You can't spend that on-
- You're not spending that online, right?
Like, no one's gonna do that. (laughing)
- It makes sense then that you
hopefully transition into it,
and when you get older and
you get more monkey brained
like myself, it becomes
really fucking annoying
when you are looking for 10 plus minutes
to just find the link to
watch what you wanna watch.
And I'm like, I will throw 10 bucks
to make this problem go away.
I wanna watch it comfortably and just-
- Yeah, reliably.
- But then there's people who argue like,
"Oh yeah, well there isn't
good services to watch anime
or read manga," there is,
it's just, most of the time
people don't wanna admit that.
Even using Crunchyroll here
in Japan, it's a bit of a pain
because I have to use a VPN.
It's still less annoying
than going to KissAnime,
opening up five fuckin' tabs,
pressing pause six times
before all the ads...
You all know this, right?
You know, you used to the
websites when you know
you're like, all right,
how many times do you have to press play
before it actually plays?
- It's three times, three
is the magic number, right?
It's always three.
- You better fucking hope to God
you don't have to pause that bitch,
'cause if you pause that bitch
and you wanna press play again,
you know you got more problems.
- I always wanna skip the anime opening
and I know to skip the anime opening,
the cost you pay is three extra clicks,
just because you wanna
skip the anime opening.
- And sometimes, you
completely fuck the buffering,
and you've got to reload the whole thing-
- And then it all starts again, right?
- and then before it plays,
you cannot allow this thing to play.
You need to skip to 1 minute 30
before it even allows to buffer,
because it might fuck up
and you cannot rebuffer.
So, I just wanna avoid that dance-
- And that's exactly why
I stopped using KissAnime
like four years ago.
'Cause I'm just like,
I'm better than this.
I don't wanna go through this torture.
- And Chromecast exists now, right?
I wanna cast that shit to my TV.
- I just wanna press one
button and it goes on my TV.
You can't do that with pirate sites, yeah.
- For android you can, right?
- Some of them you can,
but it doesn't always work.
Like, sometimes you'll be watching it
and you'll be like, okay, cool,
episode one allows me to Chromecast.
Episode two, none of these
web players on the mirrors
allow you to Chromecast, then
you're like, fuck's sake!
- It's the YouTube anime
like part seventies missing
problems all over again, right?
- It's like, do I just cave in
and just watch this on my phone
and just be really annoyed for 20 minutes,
or do I, you know...
And that happens to me
and I have to do that
because obviously sometimes
Crunchyroll doesn't have it,
and there's no way for
me to get it, and it's...
Or Netflix, fuck Netflix Japan
not having English subtitles.
- Yeah, I fucking hate that.
I've not been able to watch so many shows
that should be available to me because-
- Yeah, you put the Netflix to UK,
boom, it has English subtitles.
Why can't you just put the subtitles
on the Japanese Netflix?
You have the subtitles, why
would you not offer them?
- I don't have that problem.
- Motherfucker!
- If you wait a few months
though, it'll show up.
If you wait a few months,
the subtitles do get on there.
- Great, I'll just wait a few months,
I'll just wait a few months.
- For "Baki"-
- No, "Baki" they were
there straight away.
- Were they?
- Yeah.
- "Baki" were there straight away.
- It's fucking rolling a dice
whether Netflix will put
English subtitles on it.
It's like, Oh, maybe it will.
Maybe I'll go watch this anime,
put it on, no subtitles, fuck!
- Like one thing I never got
about some of the
reactions I see on Twitter
is, if you're gonna
pirate anime, that's fine,
I know plenty of people pirate anime.
But there's been this movement recently
that I've seen where people are just like
fucking proud of this shit.
Like, you should pirate
anime, that helps everything.
That helps the industry.
And I'm like, bro, I get it.
You wanna pirate anime? Okay.
I do it, everyone fucking
does it, you know?
But there's a difference between,
"Okay, yeah, I watched
some of my shows pirated,"
to, "Yeah, I stand up for this shit,
I'm gonna defend this shit." (laughing)
I don't get that.
- I think what it's maybe come from,
I don't know, I'm speculating here
is that you get so many influences
and people in the industry
who actively shame people who
admit that they pirate, right?
And even us, probably talking about
saying that we admit that we
pirate is a pretty risky move.
Crunchyroll could easily turn around
and be like, "We never worked
with you again," right?
Thank you for the free
account, by the way, I love it.
I do actually use my Crunchyroll account,
thank you Miles, I love you.
But, just us mentioning that we pirate,
maybe there's some other
YouTubers out there
that would be like, "How dare
you admit that you pirate?
You should be a role model to those."
- Yeah, but that's like
saying like, you know,
Oh no I didn't drink until I turned 18.
I was like bullshit,
everyone drinks before they turn 18.
- Yeah, but, you're not
there as a 16 year old
being like, "Guys, I'm
getting fucking hammered
in the middle of the fucking
city," you know. (laughing)
- I am proud to defy the law.
- Yeah I had alcohol before I was 18,
which is the legal drinking age in the UK,
but I wasn't there shouting it out
for every fucking parent to see.
I wasn't there in the fucking
off license being like,
"Hey, by the way, I'm 16,
sell me your fucking alcohol."
- I'm doing something illegal.
- I think it's so much more
approachable for viewers
and people who watch us
and especially people in
industry to admit like,
"Hey, at one point I did pirate,
but even now I still
pirate when I have to."
- What's important is the word "did",
right?
- Yeah.
- It's that you did pirate
but you don't actively only
rely on pirating now, right?
- Yeah, if I have a choice to
pay and get it done easily,
I will 'cause I'm lazy
and that's what I'll do.
But I think having this mindset
of you can never admit that you pirate,
you can never speak
doesn't have any merits.
I feel like it just
actively pushes people away
from having any form of
constructive argument.
- Yeah, because I think
actually most people
would fit somewhere in the middle.
- I think so.
- But the only takes
we see on Twitter
is either people actively
like slut-shaming piracy
or something like that-
- Or simping on piracy.
- or just simping on piracy.
And I'm like, not neither
of these are correct,
and I don't know why
these are the only takes
I see on Twitter.
- Well, I think it's wild,
one thing that drives
a lot of people away,
especially from the bigger figures,
like a lot of the voice actors
and a lot of people in
the industry is that
just actively saying, "You are
wrong, I am in this industry,
I know better than you."
Okay, there is a sense of that, right?
You are in the industry,
so maybe you have a bit more of a point,
but as far as a voice actor goes,
it's like, you have no
fucking say in what happens,
you're doing a job,
you're doing a service.
Like as far as you're concerned,
you're just in the show
and that's where your commitments end.
You've no bearing on the show.
- You're not in the industry.
- Oh no, right?
And I think that a lot
of these voice actors
are also forced then to like, you can't,
'cause the way the industry works,
you can't be to your
friend, no, you're wrong.
Because if you're seen as problematic,
like, it's serious.
If you're seen as problematic,
well maybe a director won't hire you,
'cause you're known for being
a bit of a dick on Twitter.
- Right, right.
- You don't support,
you said anime piracy was good.
We wanted to hire you,
but I guess, piracy-
- I mean, I think a lot
of people don't realize
that just actively shaming people,
will just push them
away to the other side.
And it doesn't work by saying,
"Hey, you shouldn't pirate,
this is a bad thing," even
though technically, it is.
But that doesn't mean that
people don't pirate for a reason.
- As weird as it is to say,
it's like a really weird
form of gate-keeping, almost.
It's almost like a reverse gatekeeping
where it's like, if you pirate,
then you'll not a real anime fan,
you really don't support the industry.
And it's like, no, you can.
You can eventually get to that point,
but you have to start somewhere, right?
And if piracy is your only option,
then piracy is your only option.
- I saw, like, it was like
a tweet, I don't know.
That was one of the takes that was like,
"Oh, it's not available in your country?
Tough, it wasn't made for you."
And it's like, Whoa.
It's like, yeah, okay, no one
has right to anything, right?
But also if you can't get it legally
and you're a fan of the stuff,
like, yeah, fuck it, who cares?
Pirate that shit, there's no
way for you to pay for it.
I don't understand why this
is such a, "No, you can't."
- There was another
fucking' horrible take,
which was like, "Anime is a
luxury," you remember that one?
- Oh yeah.
- We saw like this list
of horrible arguments
towards piracy, and it was
like, "Anime is a luxury,
And you should really be proven lucky
that you even get the chance
to watch any of this stuff."
I was like, it's just a fuckin'
cartoon bro, like chill.
- I know some people
who work like two jobs,
have no fucking money
and they can't afford the like
three subscriptions they need
to watch all the shows they want.
Yeah, dude, kick back and
relax, you deserve that shit.
You've been working hard,
man, I don't give a fuck.
If someone is broke as fuck,
I would not shame them for
pirating, I don't care.
- I think that we can all agree
that probably the worst take
is the whole anime merch take, right?
Like the, "I buy anime merch,
and therefore I have the right to pirate."
- I think we all buy a
lot of anime merch, right?
- Yeah.
- Used to, right?
- I used to buy a lot.
- Okay, tell us the reason why-
- Yeah, why is it past tense?
- The real reason is just, just kidding.
I can't share that. (laughing)
- It's too much tea in this episode,
the tea's being spilled.
Okay, but what are you,
as someone who actually
works in the industry,
what do you feel about that argument,
of like the, "I buy anime merch,
so therefore I have the right
to pirate," kinda thing?
- I mean, you can't use it as a reason
because I think, I don't
know how to explain this.
Like, for example, royalties for goods,
so I've heard from friends in the industry
that they go to different departments.
It's not always directly
to that specific creator.
- So, what are you saying?
If they buy merch,
the money still doesn't go
back to the original creator?
- It does, it depends, I think,
on the contract they had,
so I've heard
- Okay.
- I'm not in that department.
- I imagine the bigger
of a brand the anime is,
the easier it is to get a better deal
in terms of royalties
and costs, I imagine.
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
- Yeah 'cause one thing
that always confuses me
is that people think that,
I know there's lots of
arguments that have been made
that doing X worth is better
for supporting the industry than doing Y,
and I dunno how much, like,
I don't know where they're
getting this information from,
'cause none of these people
are working in the industry.
So every argument I see
on both sides of things
a lot of the times just anecdotal-
- It's just speculation.
- and speculation.
- There's no theory behind it.
They're just like, Oh, I
feel good buying merch.
It feels like if I buy official merch,
because it's tied to that particular IP,
you just feel like, Oh, I'm supporting it,
I'm helping to spread the love,
I'm putting money into
something that's official.
So therefore in the back of their head,
they're just like, yeah, that's
gonna go back to the creator
in some way, right?
Like they own it.
- I mean, it's better
than not doing anything.
- Of course,
but is it the best way to
support that particular creator
of the IP?
No.
- Not the best,
but better than nothing.
- So the best wages, legally streaming?
Paying for the services?
Is that the best way in your opinion?
- I've heard that the DVDs,
Blu-ray DVDs for example,
in Japan, I'm not sure about the U.S,
but in Japan, buying the
Blu-ray DVDs is the best.
That's when they know like-
- Yeah, 'cause they measure success
from Blu-ray sales, right?
- Yeah, that and like the
original sources sale-
- Yeah, like the manga
and stuff like that,
I've heard that.
- That's what I've heard.
- 'Cause I always try to
make sure I buy my manga
firsthand now.
Like, even if it's an older series
where I can easily go to
a bulk offer or something
and buy it for 100 Yen,
I always just try and go to the bookstore,
the first-hand book store.
'Cause I've heard that
is truly the best way
to support the creator, right?
- I guess 'cause when it's pre-owned-
- The royalties don't go.
- 'Cause I mean like 2/3 of my JoJo merch
is pre-owned stuff.
- That's because it's like-
- You can't get that stuff
anymore, 'cause for some reason-
- It wasn't made for you, it
wasn't available at the time.
You don't deserve it. (laughing)
- I deserve all the JoJo merch.
I spent thousands of dollars
on like Yahoo auction,
but none of that goes to...
Because a lot of the time as well,
like this merch is like
what, like 100 bucks?
And then two years later on Yahoo auction
it's 300 bucks and someone
made a nice profit.
I mean good for them.
- Araki's definitely not seen that profit.
- I mean, anything that
I've bought that's brand new
is probably the Jump store
stuff that we both bought,
'cause the JoJo exhibition
museum was canceled
and normally you have to
go to the JoJo exhibition
to get the stuff,
but they were like, "Hey, you
can just order it online."
So I ordered like-
- You got the suits.
- The suits as well I got,
but the thing is, with the suits,
that's Bandai collaboration
with Perfect Suit Factory.
So there's like two companies
that are making this thing
before it gets to the-
- They're taking most of it.
- So, like these $500 suits,
how many of that goes to Shonen Jump
and then, are like..
Like the animators aren't
seeing that shit, right?
The animators are still underpaid as fuck.
- I mean, I don't think
there's anything we can do for-
- Well, they're underpaid
because it's just Japan's salary,
the average salary in Japan-
- Mike!
- Man, Mike is taking a beating.
- The average salary in general is low.
- (Joey and Gigguk) Yeah.
- I mean, I feel like with animators,
it's a systematic problem
with how the industry works
as a whole.
- That's a whole other can of worms.
- That's also just like Japanese culture.
- Yeah, that's a whole
different argument to be had.
But I think one thing I see
with a lot of like Western
Twitter and Western people
is that I feel like they don't
want to support the industry,
mostly because they're not happy with
some of these bigger companies
or the image of like say
Crunchyroll or Funimation
and it's less of, "I don't
wanna support the industry,"
and more of, "I don't wanna
support these companies
in particular.
- Yeah, you don't wanna
support the companies
that are representing the
industry in our country, right?
- I can understand it at times
'cause there's a lot of
arguments that people make
like underpaying translators
that comes up a lot,
and you know, like last year,
it was voice actor of Funimation.
Like, there's a lot of reasons
why people might not want to, right?
It's tough, 'cause it's-
- Because I don't think there's
a right or wrong argument
but what I feel sometimes is that
a lot of people won't
support the industry,
unless there's like a perfect system
where all the money they go
to goes to this one creator.
They wanna-
- Utopian system?
- Yeah, like a utopian system
where every creator has a
fucking Patreon or something
and they can support any creator they want
and how much they want,
and that's just not a business
model, you know what I mean?
And I feel like a lot of
people use that justification
to say, "Hey we're not
supporting the creator
how I want to support the creator.
So I'm just not gonna support anything."
And I feel like there must be
a better way to go about it
than that because there's never
gonna be a perfect system.
- I mean, Trigger kinda
did the right thing, right?
They have a Patreon,
they have a Twitch stream
where they do like-
- How much does their
Patreon get at the moment?
- I'm not too sure, but-
- I think I checked,
and I was like, that is
nowhere near enough to-
- Oh no, definitely not.
It's basically just like
a side revenue for them.
But at least it's a way
that will actually go
directly to the studio,
and is a payment method or donation method
that Westerners are very
familiar with, right?
- It's good to have just an option
to do something like that.
It's like, Hey, do you wanna
directly support the studio?
And like, you know-
- I think Pixie has that.
It's not a studio, but like
there are some illustrators.
- Oh, yeah, Pixie kinda has
that as well, definitely.
But I mean, that's really the only thing
and barely anybody's utilizing it.
I've never heard of a
manga artist using Patreon.
- Is it like a pride thing in Japan?
Like not wanting to ask people for money?
'Cause like begging is
really like not a thing here.
- I don't know.
- I mean, culturally
begging is not a thing,
not even for homeless people.
- Yeah, homeless people just
do their own thing like that.
- It's true, I've never seen
a homeless person begging.
- 'Cause it's really disrespectful, right?
- Yeah, it's not a thing here.
Even the homeless here are respectful
where they're just like, "No,
no, no, keep your money."
- Like, "I'm homeless,
I still have my pride."
- I think it's just a
different culture altogether.
- There's a lot of it that
comes down to that there
I think in the industry and
how people want it to change.
It's just not going to.
- I also think a really
big root of the problem,
when it comes to at
least the anime industry
is that they truly, even
though in my experience,
having done stuff with a
lot of different studios
and productions and whatnot in anime,
they're aware of the Western industry,
they just don't really
give a shit about them.
- I would say they care a lot,
they just don't know what to do.
- It's not their first priority though.
The first priority is always
the Japanese market, right?
And that's how they measure their success.
I mean, of course I'm sure
all of these studios now,
it's 2020, right?
Like I think most of them are aware now
that there are way more Western fans
who are into their anime
than there will ever be
Japanese fans, right?
But-
- I mean, in China alone-
- Or just Southeast Asia.
- All the mobile games
coming out of China.
- Even if you just look at Southeast Asia,
that's more people just in general
who will watch the anime
and enjoy the anime
and be willing to spend the money on it.
But because the Japanese
anime industry is,
a lot of it is so old fashioned,
and thinking just locally,
that they just like,
"Okay, we understand that
there are all these people
out here who are probably
willing to pay for our stuff,
we just don't know how to do it.
We can't be bothered to
figure out how to do it."
- Japanese culture in
general though, isn't it?
- Yeah, it's just like, for example,
the DVD and Blu-ray business model
is just not going to work abroad,
you know what I mean?
I mean, it can prop up the
anime industry here in Japan
and it has for the longest time,
but it took them like how
many years to figure out
that people just don't
wanna buy DVDs and Blu-ray?
- That's like if Crunchyroll was like,
"We're gonna open up a
blockbuster tomorrow,
come on in and rent your DVDs."
It's just like, no, it's not...(laughing)
It's shocking how many people in Japan
do not know streaming services.
Like even young people are just not aware.
They're like, "Oh, you can
watch anime on Netflix?"
- They usually record it on
their TV when it's playing live.
- but it's like, I'm not
staying up until 3:00 AM
to watch a fucking run.
- I've never seen a place
where they sell CRT TV so much.
Smash players were like, "Yes, yes,"
but everyone else is like,
"Why the fuck would I need a CRT TV?
There's so many.
- I don't even know what a CRT TV is.
- Those big fucking chunky ones,
the static-
- The big TVs.
- I see so many of them for sale-
- The TV that you grew
up with, like the giant,
like the brick of a TV.
- Ow, thick.
- The thick boys, yeah.
- I was in Akihabara,
and there was like a
brand new electronic store
there was like LCD, like thin TVs,
and there's a whole section for CRT TVs.
And I'm like, who the fuck is buying this?
Genuinely, who the fuck
is buying CRT TV set,
except for Smash players?
- But like the secondhand
store here in Japan
is fuckin' on another level,
because you go into a secondhand store
and they have like fucking laser discs
in pristine condition.
- Perfect condition.
- I bought a fuckin'
like full LaserDisc set
of all the episodes of
"Evangelion" for like 500 Yen.
I don't even have a LaserDisc player,
I was just like, holy shit.
Why is this here, and why
is it such good quality?
- If you love retro games, my God,
they have every single
retro game system perf...
You can buy like an N64,
like used for like 20 bucks.
- Dude, I bought my N64 brand
new, in box for like 90 bucks.
- Yeah, you could get the SNES, in-box,
like 50 bucks in the store.
It's crazy, like Genesis games,
which are normally really
expensive in the West,
super cheap everywhere here.
Sorry, I'm going off tangent,
it's crazy how-
- It's great.
If you like retro games, come to Japan.
- Meilyne is like, what the fuck is this?
- I space out like half
the time... (laughing)
- We just talk mad shit,
Meilyne's like, "Yeah".
- Yeah, what? (laughing)
- So in your guys' opinion then,
what can be improved in the industry
and how they approach marketing
themselves to the West
and obviously never getting rid of piracy,
'cause I don't think piracy's
ever gonna disappear,
but how could you-
- Chill the fuck out,
that's what I'd like.
That's like the one, that piece of advice
I wish they would take,
just calm the fuck down.
- I think it would take
a little bit more time,
like the next five or 10 years,
it'll probably be much better.
- I think it's sad, right?
Because I think what would
take one or two years
in American companies, if you're that,
it's like 10 years in Japanese companies.
They just-
- You have to remember,
it's like an Island and-
- I know it is, I know, but it's so-
- It's really telling though,
when Japan is like still stuck in the '80s
with like how they run
their businesses sometimes.
I'm just like, it just doesn't work.
- Every single thing that's
like, why are they doing this,
it's just a cultural thing, right?
It comes back to like, you know...
- I definitely think one thing
that will really, really help
is just having an interest to listening
to what the foreign
market is doing, right?
And a great start, for example,
is like working with foreign YouTubers,
like us, for example.
'Cause I've convinced
some companies to be like,
"Oh yeah, actually, that's
a really dumb thing to do
in our company,"
and they stopped doing it
and it's worked out for them
just because we understand.
It's really telling, when we
understand the foreign market
more than the actual industry here,
and we're not even that
highly knowledgeable
or like, that in-depth about
how the industry works, right?
We've just been around it
and kind of surrounded by it.
- You see it time and time again
where a Japanese company is like dead fast
and sticking to what they
wanna do and not changing.
I mean, if you even look at
like Konami, with Kojima.
They kicked Kojima out
'cause they wanted to focus
on mobile games and Pachinko,
and that's all they fucking
do now, is Pachinko.
And sure, it's working great in Japan,
but as far as the Western
community is concerned,
Konami is a dead fucking company.
- Konami died like five years ago, yeah.
- And I think Capcom's kinda
doing the same road, right?
They made like-
- The moment Capcom axed
Mega Man, they was just dead.
- And then what was the other game
they brought out recently?
The top-down shooter
that was fucking awful?
- I don't remember it.
- I don't even know that.
- Do you keep up with them?
- Yeah, I do.
I keep up with all the game
news and it's just embarrassing,
'cause it's like all Konami
does now is Pachinko.
- These companies that
were like Goliath companies
and that everybody knew who
Capcom and Konami was, right?
- Capcom, Konami were giants in the NES.
- They just couldn't adapt
to the generation, I think.
- But even with Konami
when they had Kojima,
Kojima, was steering
them on a good journey.
I don't know inside
politics, it looked like,
I mean he was raking, like "PT" came out,
that was huge,
- Silent Hills
- Silent hills,
and they completely scrubbed
him from "Metal Gear Five".
I mean, it's time,
and that's just one really
public occasion, right?
I mean, just interacting with them,
we see this kind of stuff
time and time again,
where it's like you have the perfect idea,
and they're like, "No",
- Yeah.
- I don't know what we're
allowed to talk about
and what we're not.
- It's also hard for them
to kind of try something new
because they have no data to back it up.
- But that's the thing, right?
If no one's willing to try
anything new, nothing happens.
- There's no data for
something that's new, right?
- Are we allowed to talk
about the audio book,
for example?
- Audio book? Sure.
- Okay, so when we did the audio book-
- The Yaoi one.
- the Yaoi one,
go and buy it,
we were trynna pitch to
some of the companies
saying, "Hey, would you
mind, like, helping out
with the funding of the audio book?"
Basically, how the audio book got made
was I put all my money into it
and I hope that it sells
well I make my money back
and it's worth
one month of my life.
- Luckily did.
- Luckily you guys are
amazing, you guys bought it.
And it was, I mean, not to be-
- You're so stressed out that
month, I remember. (laughing)
- Oh my God, I was fucking losing it dude,
I was stressing out my...
'Cause it's like, when you
were in charge of it solely,
it just takes one person
to not do what they're supposed
to do to ruin everything.
And so, shout out to Seigi man,
amazing audio editor, he's came in clutch,
he did an amazing job, and
it turned out really well.
- You did two, one was a test.
- One was a test, it worked out,
we proved that it was successful, right?
So we had the data that
this would sell well.
And so we went around pitching to-
- Several different-
- basically saying, Hey you're
gonna get guaranteed sales
with this, would you like-
- And we have the data.
- Yeah, it was like, hard evidence
that this would get you at
least X amount of sales.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- It would get you X amount of sales,
you would definitely get a
return on the investment.
And none of them wanted to
like even remotely go close.
- And what was the
reasoning behind the other?
- Yeah, what was the reason?
I can't remember, it was something like,
they just didn't think
it would work, right?
- No, I think it was not that,
it's just they didn't wanna
put their money into it.
- They didn't wanna put that money
into something that they
had the hard evidence
that it would work?
- And then we, I just decided that,
'cause originally, we
were going to publishers
and being like, "Hey, do you know what,
we'll choose one of your books."
- Book Walker supported that one too,
so it was like Book Walker and
you supporting that project.
- Yeah, yeah, both of us, right?
Like we have a track
record that I've done it,
but none of these companies were willing
to even give it a shot.
Like I didn't even need that much, right?
I produced the audio book for like $2,000,
which is a lot less than like,
I mean that also helps-
- For one month of time.
- For one month at a time.
Yeah, doing it nonstop,
we made a video about it,
they were getting an insane deal.
And none of them wanted to do it,
and then we just chose one.
I just chose a book that I like, did it
and it's been like, what, like number one?
- Every month? Top 10 I would say.
- Its, yeah, top five, top three.
- That's a flex right there. (laughing)
- For like every month since it came out,
and it's just like, it's so frustrating
wanting to do these bigger projects
and none of these Japanese companies
just wanting to even
give a chance when we-
- Well that's just called bad
fucking businesses. (laughing)
- We know that it works,
we know that we can make this work.
And it's so frustrating having
to work with these companies.
- I've always been curious.
How did you convince Book
Walker, a Japanese company
to start to start working
with Western YouTubers?
'Cause I remember like,
- I wanna know how that works.
- Joey was the first one.
- Joey was the first one,
but I think Book Walker was
the first Japanese company
that ever contacted me.
I think like, still now,
one of the only ones
that have like ever gone
out and contacted us.
- Yeah, without Book Walker-
- Yeah, and that was your idea, right?
- Yeah.
- So, how did you
convince them to do that?
- I mean before, I guess
using YouTubers, I was-
- Using YouTubers, (laughing),
before we milk them dry!
- (laughing) That's a bad way to say it.
I'm sorry, before
collaborating with YouTubers-
- Get those buzzwords in Meilyne.
- 'Cause I was doing marketing for them
and I guess I still was,
I'm not in Book Walker now,
but I've tried so many things.
I've done like SNS ads,
or collaborations with the
cosplayers or fan art artists.
And I worked with anime clubs
and like, yeah, I worked with anime clubs
because they had movie nights
or they wanna have, I
don't know, manga readings.
- Oh, so you sponsor the movie nights?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You paid them?
- We gave them, like free books,
to say, "Oh, maybe you
guys should read it,"
because the idea was,
they're going to be the
ambassador of their community.
And if you give them like free
manga, they'll check it out,
and then they'll give it to their friends.
- If only there was some way
to just reach a ton of people,
really easily, like the
internet or something.
- I actually did it-
(Joey laughing)
So I was like giving them around thinking
like, what's bigger than an anime club,
what's bigger than a cosplay?
- We gotta think bigger.
- Yes!
And it's just like, four
years ago, five years ago.
- I think it's like,
four, five years ago now.
- So I didn't even know that
anime YouTube was a thing.
I knew like anime music videos,
- Very "illegal" stuff, in their eyes.
- I've made anime music
videos, but anyways,
(Gigguk and Joey laughing)
- Fired from Book Walker.
- But yeah, so I just knew about that type
of like "anime YouTube".
But then I was a big follower
of a lot of Japanese vloggers,
not Japanese vloggers, Japan bloggers,
like, J-vloggers.
And then Joey appeared
in one of the videos
of the person that I was watching,
and I was like, "This
person's called Anime Man?"
- Oh, this is, oh this, this could, hmm.
- That's some giga-brain
marketing right there. (laughing)
- So, you didn't even know
he was an anime YouTuber?
If he wasn't called the anime man,
you wouldn't have looked
into it. (laughing)
- Giga-brain marketing right there.
- I think you weren't
even talking about anime.
- If I wasn't a J-vlogger-
- I think it was like Sharla's
video, Sharla in Japan.
- Ah, yeah.
I mean, if I'm collabing with J-vloggers,
I'm not gonna talk about...
Like I can talk about
other things. (laughing)
Yeah, I don't think I
was talking about anime
at that point.
- I don't remember.
I think you were like mixing drinks.
- Oh yeah, something stupid.
- Maybe, I don't know.
But yeah, I Googled you, not Googled you,
I just clicked your videos,
and then I just started watching.
I was like, what, there's
people that review anime?
Why would anyone wanna watch that?
I hate reading people's comments.
Like for example, Crunchyroll videos,
on the bottom of the episodes-
- There's comments, yeah.
- I hate reading those-
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'cause, they might not
like the same character
or whatever.
- I don't want people to say
they don't like what I like.
- That's some garbage opinion.
- And I think I watched
like dubs are better
than subs or something,
and I was like, I don't agree
but let's see if he likes manga.
And then I emailed and I was like, "Oh..."
- Not gonna lie, the first
time I got your email,
and it said like, from like,
- Kadokawa.
- Yeah, Kadokawa,
I was just like, I think
this might be phish,
I think this might be a phishing email.
- I actually thought the same,
'cause I remember the
first time you emailed me,
immediate delete, 'cause I'm just like,
there's no way this is legit.
- Maybe I did email you,
and then I asked Joey,
he's like, you know I think
this other anime YouTuber
is not replying at all.
- (laughing) 'Cause I was like,
there's no way Kadokawa's emailing me.
- Yeah, I was like, that Kadokawa?
I only know one Kadokawa,
and it's like the anime
company Kadokawa, nooo!
- I used Kadokawa
because Book Walker is actually
kinda like a subsidiary.
It's not like Kadokawa.
It is 100% Kadokawa, but
no one knows at that time-
- 'Cause I'd never heard of Book Walker.
I always knew Kadokawa, but I'm just like,
what is this shady company that's using-
- So I was just like, Kadokawa!
- What is this shady company
that's using Kadokawa's name?
I'm like, there's no way this is legit.
- I got the email
'cause I was living in
Australia still at the time,
I'm pretty sure.
Oh no, I was in Japan.
- You'd moved here,
it was like four or six months.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I was
already in Japan, that's right.
And I remember I sent that email,
I forwarded to my mom and dad
just to be like, does this look legit?
Like, I'm really scared to reply to it.
- Why is it in English?
- Why is it in English,
and why is like, the name Meilyne?
Like, she doesn't sound Japanese, at all.
- Southeast Asian girl.
- And I was like, well, you
know, I'll give it a go.
If it ends up being a phish, whatever,
and that was the best email I ever sent.
- I asked you to come to the office too.
- That's right, that's right.
And then when you gave me the address
and I looked it up on Google maps,
I'm like, okay, this is legit.
- Because it's actually
in one of the Kadokawa's
office buildings or whatever.
- I think I heard, was it true
that Kadokawa just didn't...
like, they wanted to meet
the YouTuber before they did-
- It's not Kadokawa, it's
just Japanese businesses
in general.
Like to know if they're a
real person or just, you know,
to judge if they're good people.
- So if Joey wasn't in Japan,
would there possibly have
been no collaboration?
'Cause if Joey didn't come
to meet you guys in person-
- Our first conversation
was actually on Skype.
- Would that have been good
enough to secure a deal,
do you reckon?
- Probably not,
unless there's like a
foreigner in the group.
Like at that time, I was the
only foreigner, probably.
Yeah, I was the first foreigner.
- I remember like when I went
to the Book Walker office
as well, that was like
probably the first time
I ever went to like a
physical meeting in Japan.
And since then, God,
every time a Japanese company is like,
we'd like to meet up with
you to discuss this thing,
I'm like, do you know
what email is? (laughing)
I don't wanna leave.
- I think without like, I
mean, you guys starting it,
I feel like they wouldn't have
even considered YouTubers.
I almost feel like the Japanese
companies talking to us-
- I think it took me like
four months to get approved.
No, not four months, maybe
two months to get approval.
- Which is actually incredibly fast,
compared to some of the other projects.
- After five years,
and my number changing,
my email changing.
- I had to like B-S a lot of like data,
oh my God, I'm gonna
get caught. (laughing)
- Did you cook the
books, Meilyne (laughing)
- Maybe, like inflow from YouTube-
- I crunched the numbers. (laughing)
- I made graphs that was
like, the inflow from YouTube
is the best for reaching
the hearts of teenagers.
So I still probably have that slide,
and I was like, YouTubers are this many.
- Let's quantify how well YouTubers
can reach their viewer's hearts.
- You're probably wondering
for the past hour,
what are these figures, we
don't know what this is.
- Well, it's because this episode
is sponsored by EJ ANiME STORE.
- EJ standing for
Entertainment Japan by the way.
Carry on.
- EJ ANiME STORE is Kadokawa's
official anime store
that sells anime, gaming, manga-
- Directly from Japan.
If you didn't know, Kadokawa's
published huge titles,
such as "Evangelion"!
It's capitalized in the script.
The "Haruhi Suzumiya" series, "Re:Zero",
"Konosuba" and more.
- And because Kadokawa is
producing these directly,
what better way to support
the industry itself?
- There is no better way.
Look at all these beautiful things
that we have on the table
that are from EJ ANiME STORE,
and that you can get
your hands on right now.
Look at all this Asuna,
there's three Asunas in front,
oh actually four Asunas
in front of me right now.
- What does EJ stand for again?
- Entertainment Japan.
- To give you an idea of
the stuff that you can get
at EJ ANiME STORE, they've
brought in a few of the items-
- Oh, Jesus Christ Meilyne.
- Speak of the devil,
this is one of the things
that you can get at EJ ANiME STORE.
What is it Gigguk?
- Did you have to aim for
my face Meilyne? (laughing)
- This is from "Fates", do
you know "Fates", Connor?
It's from one of the spin-offs.
- From Fate/kaleid liner Prisma.
- So we don't have it here,
but it should be on screen,
which is the Fate/kaleid liner Prisma,
My God, the Illya Illyasviel von Einzbern
wedding bikini version
one slash scale figure.
- I'm fucking dying here. (laughing)
- What did I just pronounce?
But it does come with the
t-shirt that Gigguk is modeling
if you do buy that figure.
- Look at that, beautiful.
- This is the only Fate
franchise you should care about,
because there's lesbian wallys in it.
I don't know if I'm allowed to say that,
but it's in the shot.
- I'm also told the clothing
veil and other clear parts
are painted with pearl coloring.
The veil perio and bouquet are detachable.
- There's also this figure,
which is the Date A Bullet Light Novel:
White queen 1/7 scale figure
Kadokawa special sets.
- And this figure already looks
just absolutely incredible,
so much detail in that.
And the best part about it
is if you get this beautiful figure,
then you can also get this
lovely B2 tapestry set
with it as well-
- For free.
- for free, gentlemen.
There's also my favorite anime
series, "Sword Art Online".
This is a "Sword Art Online" figure- rise
standard Asuna Dengeki Pearl
Color limited version set,
with a beautiful Asuna tapestry as well,
that comes with it as a special bonus.
There's also these two
other Asunas as well
which has the Asuna vacation set.
I mean, she looks like
she's having a good time
on the beach there.
- Oh yeah, that's a-
- She's about to get laved up.
- There's the regular version,
and then there's the ALO version.
- If you want your own
beach episode, there you go.
- Yeah, comes with the beach.
- If you like any of these figures,
be sure to go and check them
out at ejanimestore.com,
or click the link in
the description below.
As they've only recently opened,
there'll be tons of more
merchandise coming out soon,
so stay tuned.
Entertainment Japan thank you
for sponsoring us by the way.
- Back to the video.
- So did YouTubers work Meilyne?
- I don't know, did they?
Why are you guys here? (laughing)
- I guess so.
- I think one thing that a lot of people
might be interested in,
is that you're a foreigner
working in like the anime
and manga industry in Japan.
- You're basically living the weeb dream.
- So how did that happen?
How did you find a job
in Book Walker Kadokawa
as a foreigner?
- I know the story.
- I think I know the answer.
- Craigslist Tokyo. (laughing)
- Do you wanna tell the story
about how that happened?
- Oh, well I was working at a
marketing consulting company
in Japan, and-
- Because you've been living here
'cause you had marriage
your Japanese person.
- Well, yeah, like my
first, second year in Japan,
but yeah, I was working at
a digital marketing agency,
being a consultant for several
different Japanese companies
who wanted to like get, I don't know,
global traffic to their site or something,
I've said that weird.
- That would still count as foreign,
calm down Meilyne, it's okay.
- Am I sweating? (laughing)
- Don't wipe it on the table. (laughing)
- Just fine pine.
- Where was I?
- You were talking about the global-
- Oh yeah.
You threw me off and now I'm like,
what is that even talking about?
- You were talking about
how you got the job
at Book Walker.
- Oh yeah,
and then I needed a bicycle one day
and I finished my work and
it was during lunchtime
and I was like, I can
just check Craigslist
for cheap bicycle, like
30 bucks, 20 bucks.
I'm checking on Craigslist
and then I found a bicycle.
I didn't buy it though,
and then I was like,
Oh, I wonder if there's
like actually legit jobs
on Craigslist besides like foot
massage, or whatever it is.
- 34 M looking for F.
- Yeah, 'cause you know,
that's the image that
Craigslist has in America.
- Yeah, or a fridge full of cockroaches.
- Yeah, you're the one.
You made me get that fucking
fridge full of cockroaches.
- When you buy something on Craigslist,
you first look at it in
person and then you decide.
- I'm not going to some
fucking person's house
to check out a $10 fridge Meilyne.
- Why didn't you Amazon it then?
- Because-
- Now he knows better.
- you were highly insistent
that Craigslist, may
as well be a cockroach,
- Craigslist changed my life, okay?
- You were so insistent that Craigslist,
"Dude, you should really
go to Craigslist, man,
you're gonna get a mad deal."
I was like, fine Meilyne, fine,
I'll get a fridge from Craigslist.
And then it got fucking
cockroaches in it Meilyne,
that's on you.
- But now you have a story.
- I do have a story.
I love the story, but I hate you.
- So, this job, what did it say?
What jobs did you find on there?
- Oh, I think it was like-
- Looking for F. (laughing)
- It said like digital
manga marketing specialist,
and I was like, what?
They're looking for something like that?
I click it and it doesn't
say the name of the company.
It says like, Oh, Chiyoda-ku, Iidabashi.
And I'm like, wait,
there's only two publishers
that I know of in this area.
And I was like, it's
either this really big one,
or like this kind of the big-ish one.
And I Google all the, well,
I knew it was Kadokawa,
so I was like, oh, I'm gonna Google
every single Kadokawa department
and see what they're looking for.
And then I found Book Walker
and it matched exactly kind of
what the Craigslist thing was
which was, well, looking
for someone to go overseas
to different anime conventions
to market our service.
I'm like, oh, I love anime conventions.
No Japanese required, and
this was like five years ago,
and my Japanese is nowhere fluent.
And at that time it
was even more horrible.
So getting into the anime
industry or manga industry,
you need to speak English, not English,
and Japanese like fluently,
like beyond business.
And so I was like,
Oh I'm never gonna work
in the manga industry,
unless it's like in America,
then I could like apply.
- Glad you got it.
- Oh, yeah!
- That's like insane,
'cause if I saw that ad on Craigslist,
again I would think he was
a scammer or something.
Like imagine Kadokawa
going on like advertising
a fucking job on Craigslist.
- They didn't say the company name though,
it's just location.
- But it's still on Craigslist.
That makes it even more sketchy, right?
- I fully expected to
just be like Kodokawa,
just like one letter off, right?
It's like, oh, it almost sounds
like Kadokawa. (laughing)
- It's like a certain rent-a-girlfriend,
that was like TamelyMart?
I was fucking losing it.
With all the letters, TamelyMart?
I don't know why it was so funny.
- The golden oldie, walkdonalds?
Never gets old, never gets old.
- I gonna do a video on
Craigslist, I remember.
Why are you laughing?
I suck dick for video. (laughing)
I wanted to see what was on there,
and so I found this ad that was like
looking for YouTubers below 10,000.
And I was like, what?
What is it all about?
This was in London, so I called them up
and it was, no, no, not Japan.
I was gonna feel weird
about that in Japan.
And so I called them up,
and they were like, "Yeah
we wanna pay YouTubers
below 10,000 subscribers,
$5,000 to move to our
platform exclusively."
It was a woman on the phone,
I didn't tell her I had
like a million subs.
And she was just like, she was going on,
and she was like, yeah,
so we just need you
to be in an exclusive deal
with our partners and all this.
I was so confused, I was like, what the?
I never heard of this
platform since, right?
And then they were like, Oh yeah, but...
'cause I was a guy, obviously,
they were like, yeah, but
we're only interested in women
as well.
And I was like what the fuck?
- That's like red flags coming up, yeah.
- I was like, I don't know.
I wonder if I like stumbled
onto the greatest prostitution
network or something.
I don't know what it was,
'till this day, I still don't know,
I have the phone call recorded on my PC.
And then I told them I had a million subs
and then they, they were like,
oh no, we're not interested.
And I was also like-
- Why 10,000?
- I was really confused about that.
- Is it because if they
wanna like drop out,
for example, it's just like trauma.
They're like, Oh, this
guy's only got 10,000 subs,
they won't go anywhere.
- They kept saying stuff that
was like too good to be true.
They were like, one, we'll
give you $5,000 to move,
we were in the UK as well by the way,
that was already like, that's weird.
And then also they were like,
we can give you premium ad
rev rates of like $10 CPM.
I'm like, get out of here.
$10 CPM? Fuck off, no
way, I was losing it.
To this day, I still
don't know what that was.
I didn't know why I told that story.
- Did you even check
their website thoroughly?
- They wouldn't me what it was.
They were like, it's down-low,
it's on the down-low.
I'm like, that's weird.
- That sounds sketchy as fuck, man.
That sounds like a hiring
ring for like a prostitution,
like a black market prostitution.
- That's why I never wanna use Craigslist,
because every single story
I've heard from Craigslist, is,
a part from yours-
- Apart from Meilyne's.
- Outside of Japan, I think
Craigslist is a sketch.
- Have you gone to like the
section where you can, you know,
pay for favors?
- You can?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Oh no, that's like the community
or something right there.
- There's one where it's
like for old people,
it's all just like 40, 50 year old women
looking for like dudes
to just give them a good-
- Is this in Japan?
- Yeah, and UK, in the
U.S, I checked all of them.
'Cause I wanted to see
if there's anything crazy
about Craigslist.
- Don't tell me you're
gonna make a video on it.
- No, I will not.
- Okay, thank God.
- Don't tell me that's where
all the hot sexy singles
(laughing) in my area,
they're all on Craigslist,
not KissAnime, God-damn it.
- That's why you're not
home sick. (laughing)
- What if you just clicked
on the KissAnime ads
and it just takes you to the Craigslist?
It makes sense. (laughing)
- It's wild, 'cause there
was like 40 year old women
who were married showing their face
and giving them mobile phone number.
And I was like, whoa, you are
playing with fire, surely.
- That doesn't sound safe.
- But also you're married, right?
I saw your face, Karen.
- Every Karen is like-
- You don't know if it's their real photo.
- Yeah, true,
- It could be very much a scam.
- It definitely has to be
their number though, right?
I mean...
- I guess we have to find out by calling.
- I guess there's only one
way to find out. (laughing)
I would totally call her just
for a video, I'd do that.
I mean, I have like, no
qualms about doing that.
- But steering back to the conversation,
so I think we can all agree
that Meilyne's story is very
much a rare case, right?
Like I-
- Is it a rare case?
- I think so.
I've never heard of anyone
getting into the anime industry
through Craigslist.
- I think it's 'cause
people who you probably,
most people know or you
guys know are in the U.S,
working for U.S.
- Was there ever a time you wanted to work
in the U.S industry? (laughing)
What is that smile?
- That smile paints just 1,000 words.
That's the most nervous
smile I've ever seen.
- Yeah, there was two companies
that I applied to that were-
- Did you get rejected Meilyne?
Did you get rejected?
Is that why you-
- But they called back
and they're like, "You
are the second candidate
we were thinking about."
- That hurts even more, I don't hear that.
- That was like when I
was a fresh graduate.
- Do you wanna know if
you haven't got the job?
I don't wanna know, I just wanna apply
and move on.
- I wanna know.
I also wanna know the reason.
- They're never gonna give it to you.
- I guarantee to every
person they dropped,
they said, "You were the second one."
Guarantee it.
- Honestly, we wanted to.
- That's what I would do. (laughing)
But what would be, cause
I'm fucking certain,
that not just people
watching this episode,
but I reckon like every
weeb living overseas
probably has that dream somewhere
in the back of their head
where they're like, man
I wanna move to Japan,
I wanna work in the anime industry.
- Did you get those emails as well?
- Yeah, I get them.
- Everyone gets them,
we all get them.
So as someone who actually made it,
what is the advice you would give
to people who want to chase that dream?
- It took a year and a half, I think.
- That's pretty fast though for Japan.
No, no, no, you didn't get
the green card to move here.
- 'Cause I was like what? No.
- I mean, that's the
easiest way there, right?
I mean, there's probably
guys that say like,
I can marry someone to get in?
- Actually, no, not really, I mean...
- But what advice would you give
for someone who's looking
to work in the industry-
- In Japan?
- Yeah, in Japan.
- The most realistic way.
- I would say learn some Japanese,
that's like the easiest way to get in.
Not flown, like, there's that JLPT
where it's N1, N2 or whatever.
And I've heard like, Oh, N2 is sufficient.
- If you can get to N2, you
can pretty much snag any job
that's not too language-focused.
- Or be extremely knowledgeable
about the industry.
That's like the biggest thing.
- 'Cause people ask us all the time,
they're like, "What's the best way?"
And I'm like, bro, I'm like
in the weirdest situation.
- Don't take my career path,
that's a really weird career path.
- We just wanna stress, we're
not part of the industry.
We work with the industry.
- We are not part of the industry.
- Why are you asking a
YouTuber on immigration law?
I don't know anything, you
think I know immigration law?
Fuck, dude.
- You should,
because you immigrated here, right?
- I barely know how to file
my taxes correctly, come on.
- But are a lot of Japanese
companies hiring foreigners?
- Yes, yes they do actually.
Quite a lot are, especially
in the past year or two,
they've expanded to the global market.
- Why are you-
- 'Cause people watching this
are like, "Write that down,
write that down!" (laughing)
- Open tab, Craigslist.
- Japan knows how popular
anime is overseas,
that's why, of course, there's
like the cool Japan thing.
- If Book Walker did a
job application today,
what would my CV, my
resume need to look like?
What are we looking for?
- And you can tell us this
because you're probably gonna be like,
if a job opening ever opens up
you'd probably be the one
doing the interview, right?
So what would-
- What do you expect
from someone who wants to work in there?
- I don't know, I'm not
in like that team anymore.
- Give us your thoughts Meilyne, c'mon.
- Like hypothetically,
'cause you almost have
to hire for GeeXPlus,
which is also very similar.
- Don't be like an incel or something.
Like don't be a nervous wreck-
- So a bit of charisma.
- And have like a social life, kind of.
'Cause you got those really weird-
- That's a real tall order for weebs.
- When they come in, can
you sense it straight away?
- Oh, we did some like
interviews recently actually
where we were like, we did it through zoom
or like video call, and
the thing I was looking for
is like, they smile and like...
And then I also, like, we ask them,
what's your favorite
anime series or something
and it's not the anime series they choose,
it's the reason why they
like it or whatever.
- If they say Nomi, get
outta here. (laughing)
- It's like, "Oh my God,
he said that series," no.
- Every application you're
gonna have from now on
like every CV, it's
just like, not an incel.
- Not and incel, smiles in a zoom call.
- And they have to have experience.
I would say experience
is like the biggest thing
because-
- Experience in what?
- Working, like in a company actually.
- Anything?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I feel like
that's a lot of experience
that a lot of people
are missing, you know.
Just working in a company environment
is actually really valuable in my opinion.
- Corporate experience, definitely.
- Or if they're like fresh graduate,
at least have a few
internships under your belt.
'Cause there's some people
in my previous companies
I've worked with in the past,
like they're new graduates,
they go into the job
and they don't even know how to use Excel.
So if they're familiar with
all the Microsoft stuff.
- I mean, it's something you
never like actively learn
how to use, like Excel and Word,
but it's such a necessary skill to have
working in a corporate job,
which is knowing how to use Excel.
It's not in any job
application, but it's...
When I was working in the BBC,
I had to use Excel for fucking everything.
- I'm convinced my engineering degree
was an Excel degree in disguise.
I'm convinced, 'cause we
used Excel for everything.
- We had classes in high school
that were specifically towards Excel.
- So what's like the
main points on a resume.
Like if there's three most
things that you can have
as a candidate for applying.
- What stands out the most for you?
- We're not talking about
like, don't be an incel.
- I'm not like the final
judge with this thing.
- No, no, no, but just like your opinion.
- Just the way they write
their intro paragraph
about themselves.
- Right.
- Oh shit, that's actually important.
- For me, I read it and I'm
just like, what do they say?
Did they sound passionate
or they're just copying
and pasting top 10 best
ways to write a cover letter
or something.
- In Japan, don't you
have to write every letter
and resume by hand?
- Yeah.
- That's disgusting.
- Oh my God, that's too much.
- So what's that little job fair they do
when they leave school,
what's that called?
Where they spend a year trynna-
- Oh, shukatsu?
- Yeah, and they can write
up to 100 applications
by hand, the same shit.
- Yeah.
- I would lose my damn mind.
- I had to do that when I
was applying for internships
in Japan, I think I wrote 30.
And that wasn't nearly as much
as some of my friends did.
- Apparently they look out
for like, if you care enough,
and I'm like, to me, that seems like,
why is this the thing
that we're caring about?
- I don't care, I just want money.
Give me the experience-
- I'm here to make you money, shut up!
- Can we just be honest here
and just say, why do you need this job?
Because I'm broke and I just graduated
and I need the fucking money, okay?
I need a job!
- Just give me the job, fucking hell.
- Do you like it when they're
extremely passionate too.
Like not saying like, "Oh my God,
I'm like a huge Love Liver,
and I've "Love Live" for everything."
It's more like, you know,
I was in a different time.
- Shout out to the Love Livers.
- I would never hire
someone who's obsessed
with "Love Live", you know why?
Because that loyalty would
never lie with you, ever,
no matter what.
- But you can bribe them.
- That's true, but for
how long can you bribe?
How long can you bribe them, Meilyne?
- If you don't finish
this, I'm ripping it.
- Your phone just slammed
on the floor, very dramatic.
But okay, let's say, they're
addicted to "Gancha".
Who knows how long it is
before they do one too
many "Gancha" rules.
They coming at you with a raise,
they want a raise, Meilyne.
- They wouldn't ask me,
they would ask the CEO for the raise.
- Okay, but hypothetically,
if you were the CEO,
then how would you respond to that?
- Well, first I would ask,
oh, what have you been doing
this past year differently?
And how much have you affected this?
Like how much has the sales
been affected by your work?
And what do you wanna
try doing differently?
If I gave you this much money,
what are you going to do?
Is it really going to better your life?
- So it's basically another job interview,
is what I'm hearing.
- I mean, I don't have any underlings.
- Underlings, my God! Overlord over here.
- Because one thing I find fascinating
is how the story of like,
we all have you to thank
for this podcast and being here in Japan.
- It takes an awful lot.
- An awful lot of what we've
done is thanks to Meilyne.
She's like the brain child to a lot of it,
but I find this-
- I just got lucky, okay?
- But how did the story of
GeeXPlus forming come to be?
Because you made GeeXPlus.
- GeeXPlus is the agency
that we're all under,
and the reason why we're here.
- And the reason why we're here.
So how did that come about?
- Like Kadokawa has a new business contest
or competition every year,
and then within their departments
they also do business competitions.
And the first year I
decided to submit something
and it was the GeeXPlus thing.
And usually, well, I didn't
wanna submit it before
'cause there was like, the
prize money was like this much.
And then this particular year
the prize money was like this,
and I was like, maybe I want that money.
- So wait, wait, I gotta ask,
because I remember the exact
meeting where you asked me,
she asked me in the meeting,
"Have you ever considered
moving to Japan?"
- Yeah, we were just casually talking.
- Yeah, just casually talking.
But did you have that prize money
and that competition in
mind when you asked me?
- Yeah. (laughing)
(Gigguk laughing)
- Yeah, man, I respect it.
- I respect the hustle.
Like, "I don't give a shit about
these YouTubers coming out,
I want that cold-hard cash."
- Are you allowed to
tell us how much you got?
- Okay, people will say,
"Oh, it's not that much."
But it was like, I think
they told me was like,
Oh the price is going to be like (beep).
- That's like a decent bonus.
- Yeah, it's not bad.
- But what I wanna know
is how you managed to convince them
because as we've all talked about,
Japanese companies are fucking difficult-
- They never wanna try anything new.
- to try anything new.
And convincing a Japanese company
to send over like three or four AniTubers
and just sponsor their
visas and help get up.
- Well, I had an advantage.
You guys have been working
with Book Walker for,
at that point, like two,
three years already?
So I had data, and they love data.
- We know from the Yaoi audio book,
that that's not always the case, right?
Like that's not guaranteed.
- That wasn't enough though.
This is like three years worth.
- Never enough.
- It's all about that data.
- The Excel sheets, the Excel sheets.
- Exactly, Excel sheets and PowerPoints.
And so I think in the back of their mind,
they were already thinking like,
Oh if we had this business,
it would be interesting.
And my superior, Ross, at
that time was giving me a tip
Oh, maybe you should submit that idea
'cause maybe they're thinking about it.
And I was like, okay, I
guess I have enough data,
so let's do it.
And then I won the thingy, and then-
- Did you have like, was it
like an apprentice type pitch
where you had to go into
like a boardroom meeting and-
- I attended one.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
I was the, like, first week I moved here,
they were like, do you
wanna come to this thing?
- Yeah, and then you
met Mr. Kadokawa, like-
- Yeah, it was weird.
'cause I just sat down
in the most sterile room
you can imagine.
- Imagine just like 100,
200 Japanese businessmen
and the quietest room in
your life and I came in,
'cause I came in midway,
so I was making so much fucking noise
just trynna to sit down,
of course my seat was in the middle-
- And you're the only non-Asian in there.
- I was like the only,
like I was the only one not
on the suit of some sort
as well.
So I come in with like
my t-shirt and jeans,
making some noise.
I'm like, excuse me, excuse me.
Sat down, and then one
of the Japanese people
kept translating in my ear
and I'm like, just stop translating,
you're making too much noise,
and people are looking at us.
I'll just pretend like
I know what's happening.
But they were all really
good sports about it,
they were nice to me afterwards.
- Just like that, we had
like a new business plan
format document, you fill it out.
And then within that,
I think it was like over 200,
maybe around 200 applicants.
And then it narrowed down to like 50,
and then when you're the
top 50, they narrow it.
You don't do anything, you just
like make like a three year-
- Business plan?
- Yeah.
- Where did I go?
- What?
- Why did I go again?
There was free food and drink,
that was it.
That was really good sushi and free beer,
so it was really good, sorry, go ahead.
- If there's free food and
drink, I'll go to anything.
- Okay, not gonna lie, right?
- And you were bored,
probably, you had no friends-
- I had no internet.
- They didn't arrive yet.
- They weren't there.
I think I felt bad
'cause I'd been crashing
on Joey's couch for like a week.
I felt really bad that
was bothering him so much.
- Yeah, it's fine.
- I know, I know.
And then, okay, this is the thing, right?
Company parties, at least in Japan,
they don't spare any
expense with food and drink,
they like do such good food and drink.
Okay, Meilyne's a food snob,
I don't count her opinion.
- I thought it was good,
it was good, it was okay.
- But they have like bomb food and drink.
It's always so good.
They'll have restaurant quality
food just there for you,
and you're like, yeah, okay,
yeah, I wanna try that.
- It is a restaurant though.
- Well, no, it's like a hotel
and then just bring in a platter
and you're just like, dig in.
- It's like, sweet.
- And all you can drink alcohol.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, that was good.
- People, awkward people,
and the Japanese women taking
photos 'cause you told them.
- Yeah, they were like-
- They were like, "This is
the guy who made the Yaoi,
the one that we're going to
check for the sex noises."
- The Book Walker support team,
I think they're mostly women, and then...
- That was so weird.
- This is the man. (laughing)
- They're like all fan girls
of you I think. (laughing)
- The 93%, back at it again.
- Let's go, let's go.
- I was so confused
'cause like none of them
could speak English.
So I was like, why are
you listening to my stuff?
- Some of them are.
The reason why they knew about you
was because I think it was last year
when we did the first audio book,
they were playing it on speaker
because they would get
like emails from customers
saying, "Oh I don't know
how to play this MP3,"
and so they're like, "Oh, let's
check if there's a problem"
and they play it and they just
end up playing it on speaker.
- Did they play the new one on speaker?
The new one has like a
hardcore sex scene at the end.
- No, because, what is it, Corona virus?
They were working from home.
- So they played it on
the speakers at home.
- Yeah, probably.
- That was weird, 'cause
then I was just eating,
and then they were like,
"Can we take a picture?"
And I'm like, "Who are you?"
Why are you-
- We're your fan girls.
- It was so weird.
- So did you expect to win
the competition at all,
or was it like a fucking surprise for you?
- Kind of a surprise, I guess.
- I knew I was the best.
- No, like my boss at the time was saying
like, Oh you have like,
maybe a high probability
because he was the one reviewing
the other business things.
So maybe he helped me a lot, thank you.
- I mean, it's a pretty
radical idea, right?
Especially in such a traditional
company like Kadokawa.
- Do you know what other ideas
you were competing against?
- Yeah, there were kinda
like manga service,
like manga subscription
or something like that.
- That would be good as well.
- I mean, that would be good for japan.
- JP, ever heard of that? (laughing)
- So, I kinda want to talk
about the opening party
of GeeXPlus,
because that was probably
the most extra business party
I've ever been to.
- Oh my God!
- So sad I wasn't there.
- So Connor wasn't there
because he was at the
Crunchyroll anime awards.
So he was, there was about like 10 iPads
scattered around this entire like-
- Three.
- Three iPads,
okay, three iPads, whatever,
scattered around this like
two-star Michelin restaurant.
What was the restaurant
that it was held at?
- Iniwa.
- It's owned by Kadokawa, right?
- So I didn't know that
Kadokawa owned so many things
outside of just like anime
and manga.
- Multimedia.
- Yeah, and so we were at this
two-star Michelin restaurant
and Connor had to join
us via Skype or zoom
or whatever you were using.
- That was like a stupid
time for you, right?
- I was like-
- Your face was like this.
- It was like, yeah, like
10, 11:00 PM or something.
And then I had to do a speech
and it was like the most
fucking awful speech.
- I remember you were in
the fucking hotel room,
like a downward angle.
- 'Cause I was just like,
(speaking in Japanese).
- He said it all in Japanese,
and I was like, wow!
(Connor speaking Japanese)
- To explain, so this is like,
there are a lot of important
people at this party.
- How many people were there?
Maybe like 50 plus, right?
- Yeah, 50 plus.
Basically they was like,
Mr Kadokawa was there,
there was like pretty
much any anime company-
- MyAnimeList CEO
- The CEO of MyAnimeList was there,
I didn't even that he
was Japanese, you know.
- Danny Choo was there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, basically any
company that is in Japan,
any big company, there
was a representative
for that company there.
This was like the biggest dick energy
I've ever been-
- And Connor on an iPad.
- I remember we had to do a speech
in front of all these important people.
And I remember the CEO of GeeXPlus,
he introduced us to make our speech.
And I was like fucking shitting myself
because man-
- I could see you were shitting yourself.
- I was shitting myself
because I had to talk in front
of all these fucking people
and I couldn't speak a lick of Japanese.
So I had to speak in English
but I remember that he introduced us
and I remember hearing something like,
"Oh, the heroes of anime."
And I turned to Joey,
and I was like, my Japanese
isn't the greatest,
but did he just call
us the heroes of anime
for Western anime fans?
And Joey was just like,
"Yeah."
- Yeah.
- And I was just thinking to myself,
why would he lie like that?
- The heroes of anime.
I was just like doing the blinking meme,
I was like, what?
- To be fair though, I
would say it's kinda true.
Like there's a lot of people that-
- There's a lot of people
who would disagree with that.
- A lot of people call
us the villains of anime
if anything, right.
- Some people would probably,
who are in the middle of nowhere
that have no anime friends
and they're getting bullied for it,
and they're like, "Oh
these people like anime
and they're actually cool?"
- Yeah, punch 'em back.
- Anime is not a lame thing?
Yes, you're cool.
- All I remember was, I was suited up,
Sydney was suited up
and then Joey walks up in fuckin'...
I can't remember what you were wearing.
- I was in a JoJo shirt, and like shorts.
And I looked at Gigguk,
like so properly dressed
with like collar, shirt and everything.
Sydney was in like this really nice dress,
and I'm just there with like
my jeans and fucking sneakers,
and I'm just like, "Ss'up,
hero of anime right here."
- I took that to another party as well.
- This is like, "Oh my God,
that's how YouTubers dress?"
That's like, you know...
Celebrity wear.
- Celebrity wear?
- Celebrities wear like jumpsuits.
- I'm so celebrity, I
wear Uniqlo everywhere.
- Yeah, I don't think
that anyone understood
what I actually said in my speech.
You're the only one who
anyone could understand.
- I was told no one could hear me.
- A lot of them did speak English though.
- Because you started speaking
and the speakers just weren't on.
All we could see was-
(Joey laughing)
- It's an amazing speech,
it such a good speech.
- What was more hilarious
was just not only just
Connor's speakers not being on,
but just 50 Japanese business men,
just like really seriously
just looking down at the iPad,
just being like...
- They were paying attention.
- You have to bear in mind as
well, I can't see anything.
Like I'm just talking to a
webcam, I don't see shit.
So as far as I know,
like I'm just talking in
the fucking void over here,
with my shitty Japanese,
(speaking in Japanese).
Oh my God.
- That was really funny.
- But no, that was like a
really interesting experience
for me 'cause that was
like a holy shit moment.
Have I made it? Is this the point?
- We met some really
fuckin' cool people there.
- Who was like, the person you
met that stood out the most?
Or which company did
you like freak out over?
- Obviously like the Shonen
Jump guys were there,
but I think the coolest one,
just because it just kinda
came out of nowhere was,
I think I was talking to
the Shonen Jump people,
and they were like,
what manga do you like?
What are you interested in?
Obviously I laid out a
bunch of Shonen Jump stuff
and then one of the guys was like,
"Oh, what about stuff
that's not Shonen Jump,
like I'm just genuinely curious."
And I think I said "Berserk"
because I fucking love "Berserk".
And then literally the moment
after I said "Berserk",
some guy tapped me on the shoulder
almost like, "Hi, I'm
the publisher 'Berserk'."
I was like, (gasping)
- The editor.
- Was things like dusty?
He's like, "I've never done that."
I've been hired for five years
and I haven't done anything.
- I've never even met Miura
in my life. (laughing)
So, he said that and I read the card.
I'm like, Oh shit, yeah,
that is like the publication of "Berserk".
And I just said, like, "Not to be rude,
what the fuck is Miura doing?
What is he doing?"
- What's going on?
- What's going on with that?
- Let's jump right into it.
- Like, "You're his publisher right?
Just give me the details,
what's he doing?"
And he's like, "Oh no, he's
working hard, don't worry."
I'm like, "Yeah, that's what
they all say." (laughing)
- Idol master in the
background, "I'm working hard."
- Are you winning, son?
- Yeah, but that was really cool,
Danny Choo was really cool-
- Danny Choo was really cool.
- because I think it's safe to say
that Danny Choo she is one of those people
who really put anime weeb
culture in the West on the map.
Because I think it's not
too much of a stretch
to say that without
Danny Choo's influence,
I don't think any of us would
really even be interested
in Japanese culture,
especially people on the West.
- He did so much for,
not only like our culture
but our industry as well.
'Cause he was one of the first
foreigners who moved to Japan
and really put a highlight
on a lot of things
going on in the Japanese industry.
- He had to blog about it.
- Yeah, exactly,
'cause before, I remember it was just like
Japan was just kind of a black hole.
Nobody knew shit that
was happening in Japan,
we just got anime somehow.
But he actually spotlighted
a lot of the things going on,
and if not for him,
I probably wouldn't even
have even considered moving
to Japan or have any interest
in the industry itself.
- He did some great motivational speeches
at a lot of events like anime expo.
- And he's a really down
to earth guy as well.
- He's so humble, incredibly
incredibly humble.
- Everything he's done,
he's like so humble
and so down to earth.
- He just showed up with his doll.
- Yeah, he showed up with this smart doll,
yeah, that was so cool,
shout out to Danny Choo.
But you should have been
there bro. (laughing)
- I'm pissed off I missed out.
- How was the Crunchyroll
anime awards compared to that?
(Joey and Gigguk laughing)
- I mean, one day I
came back into my room,
and there was a trash bag full
of stuff that wasn't mine.
Can you believe that?
- In your hotel?
- In my hotel room.
- Who went in there?
- I don't know.
I called them up and I'm like,
Hey, there's a, just a giant
bag of trash in my room.
What's up with that?
And they're like, "Really?"
They didn't believe me.
I'm like, come, come.
- The maids probably cleaned up.
- Well I think what they did
is the maids were cleaning
and they just forgot the
bag, so I didn't care much.
They gave me a letter that was like,
"Dear CDawg, sorry that we
left trash in your room."
And I was like, why is it CDawg?
- Probably the name that
they put on the reservation?
- No, it was Connor,
'cause I checked in with
my real name and I know,
the guy must have known or
something, it was weird as fuck.
'Cause then he gave me
another bottle of wine,
but it was like a terrible
hotel screw-cap wine,
I'm like, I wouldn't
even cook with this shit.
No offense, it's like, it
was fuckin' garbage wine.
I mean, I'm not picky,
but even I knew that.
- How was the actual awards?
- Yeah, how was it for you?
'Cause we both went on different years.
- I imagine it was the same for you,
the best aspect was just
chatting to the other creators.
- It felt like a holiday,
where you just got to meet other creators.
- I got to eat Chipotle, I've
been missing Chipotle a lot.
I was like, 'cause we would
all eat lunch together,
and I was like, "Chipotle,
I want Chipotle,"
and then one of the, I
forgot her name, from IGN.
I think she was Hispanic,
and she was like, "No,
Chipotle's garbage."
I'm like, "Listen, I come
from a place recently
where they don't have any Chipotle.
Do you know how hard
it is to find a burrito
bigger than like your index
finger in this country?
Impossible."
- I think out of every cuisine
Mexican is one of the
hardest to find in Japan.
- I want a burrito that
like fucking kills me.
So anyway, it was nice
having lunch with them.
Sorry, I'm going on a rant there.
But yeah, it was pretty
cool, the offices were cool,
they've made it into like-
- Yeah, you got to see
the offices, didn't they?
- Yeah, it was cool.
I mean, I felt like a little
extra, like, I don't know,
there was a lot of free LaCroix,
I didn't really care for LaCroix.
- What's LaCroix?
- You know LaCroix, right?
It's like the meme drink.
- It's like the most
disgusting thing I ever had.
- Is that like White Claw?
- No, LaCroix is like, it's like salted?
- Flavored, sparkling water.
- It was weird, 'cause I think
you went two years in a row.
- Yeah, and I didn't go to the one
where they were streaming
out, the Twitch headquarters.
Where they streaming
at the Twitch quarters?
- No, they were streaming in their office.
- Oh, okay.
- So that was like a back room
with a small crowd of about
100 people, and it was fine.
I really got bored of how many
times you had to practice.
- How many times did you have to rehearse?
' Cause we only-
- Four times.
- we only had to rehearse once.
- Four fucking times.
- Jesus, four?
- What were they rehearsing?
- I think it was for the host,
'cause obviously, he had a lot of lines.
For me it was easy, I just,
oh, during the rehearsals,
by the way, I mean gone...
Okay, so I gotta tell the story.
So they wanted us to have
a mixture of scripted
and do your own stuff as I
think it should be, right?
Like, I want to be on track,
but I also wanna be myself.
So they would ask me a
question that was kind of,
"Who do you think is best skilled?"
And during rehearsals,
I never said like anything
even remotely Mimi.
I was like, "Oh yeah, like Rem."
And then I texted Gigguk like
an hour before the show start,
I was like, "Yeah, give me the worst girl.
Give me the worst, best girl,
And I will dead-ass say
this like straight face
in front of all these
people, like I'll do it.
I'll do it on the Twitch
stream, I don't mind."
'Cause I thought, I wanna make this funny.
In a good way, that wasn't
fucking with Crunchyroll,
but there's a way that we could
get a bit of laughter out.
- I said Nina from "Code Geass",
that was the first name that came to mind.
- I remember I said that joke
and the fucking crowd's like,
no one got it.
- I watched the stream.
- I was fucking pissing myself.
- I thought to myself,
'cause I knew no one was
gonna laugh at this joke,
and I just thought to myself,
I was like, the Twitch
chat, they're gonna love it,
Twitch chat's gonna love this.
I don't mind, I'll just put
up with the awkward silence
for like one second.
- I was watching the Twitch stream,
and the moment you said that, I died,
Twitch chat was fucking loving it,
- But the crowd in the audience
and everyone's there, dead.
- I remember the moment I said it,
for some reason, Jacob
from Fakku was in the crowd
and I just made eye contact with Jacob
and he looked like this.
I was like, and I think I
made like a joke or something,
I made something to
like try and segway it,
and it didn't work very well obviously,
but I didn't give a shit.
- It made for a great clip
because it was like so
perfectly timed of my stream,
'cause I was like, yeah,
I told Connor to say Nina,
and as soon as I said that, you said it,
and it was just like the
most perfectly timed moment
I could ever hope for.
- Asked me, what he should say for this,
in the chat, he was like,
"They're gonna ask me
who the all time best girl is."
- What'd you tell him?
- I told him, say Nina from
"Code Geass". (laughing)
- [Panelist] Connor?
- Umh, Nina from "Code Geass".
- Oh my god!
- Yeah, it was, it was good.
I mean, it was fun, we
hung out in the green room
or whatever, it was
chill, just chatting with,
I remember, I chat with
ProZD, really cool guy.
That man knows his anime,
he knows a lot of anime.
- He knows so much anime.
because I had a similar
conversation with him
and I'm like, man you know,
more anime the most AniTubers.
- We were just in this
room and it was silent,
then you would just hear someone playing
the fucking "Love Live".
Just ProZD sitting there like this.
- He's a Love Liver?
- He's a hardcore Love Liver.
- I love it when like, when he would talk,
'cause it would be like
whenever ProZD talked,
everyone in the room was like,
"Yes, ProZD, I'll listen to you."
He got such a commanding
voice, it's amazing.
- Who has the deeper voice in real life?
- It's like just two mumbles
talking when they're talking,
because he's like, "Get McDonald's,"
I be, "Yeah, I'll get McDonald's."
- The subwoofer on this
conversation is ridiculous.
- Overall it was good.
I think that the parts I remember the most
are like not the actual, like awards.
- Same, I don't remember anything,
all that happened was
that when I was on stage.
'Cause I remember when I
was on the Crunchyroll,
it was a big fucking crowd.
How big was your crowd?
- Like no more than 100.
- Right, 'cause we were like,
they rented our whole
stage in LA or something.
They had like a red carpet,
which like, an orange calm.
It was charming about like,
'cause it was still like
a small scale event,
but they really tried to dress this up
to look like something official.
And you know, there was a
lot of technical difficulties
and mess up, but that's
probably like, you know,
if you watch the streams-
- The technical difficulties
in that year were glorious.
- They made for like great meme material.
And it was like charming in its own way
because it wasn't like The Game Awards,
it wasn't the fucking Oscars,
but you know, they tried their best.
And I think for what they had,
they did like a pretty decent job.
- B plus for effort, I'd say.
- I think they said that
they wanted to dial it back
this year to make it a little more like
have personality shine through a bit more.
But it's still hard
because I think sometimes
some people aren't as
good on stage as others.
- Is that your first
time kind of "hosting"?
- I wasn't doing anything?
- He was literally just sitting
on a couch, cracking jokes.
- The only thing I was nervous
about was cracking that joke,
'cause I knew that was gonna,
I knew no one would laugh,
but I didn't mind.
But other than that,
I really don't mind doing
stuff like that, that's fun.
- I remember the only
weird thing that happened
when I was on stage was, I
was standing next to Lily
'cause I was hosting with Lily Puchi
when I was presenting my award,
and so I was staying at the bright lights
and all I heard was, (muffling)
and I thought someone
said, "I love you guys."
And I shout out in the Crunchyroll awards,
"I love you too, man."
And then I've watched the vods,
and the guy shouts out, "I
love you, Lily." (laughing)
- That would be even better.
I would be like, no, I love you.
- You may not love me, but
I love you unconditionally.
- I mean, I don't think
anyone noticed there,
but yeah, I thought
you were just screaming
for us both there.
- When they did the final award,
at Crunchyroll anime awards,
they had like a giant,
like what is it called?
The fucking thing they open, what's it?
- Sake?
- No, I think it is, they all had Sake,
that's part of the story,
but they have like the
big boxes that we had,
like the names of the winners in,
the anime of the year
had like a giant one.
- Oh yeah.
I don't know what they're called,
I know what you're talking about though.
- So when they did the giant one,
they were like, "Yeah, okay,
everyone's gonna go on stage
and we have a fake Sake
for you, it's water."
And I was like, oh cool, cool, cool.
So I have it right, and I'm
smelling it like next to Lily.
I think you can see me
and Lily in the VODs,
like visual confusion,
because we do it, I'm like,
"That's fucking Sake."
They told us it was fucking water!
Me and Lily are like,
"God that's fucking vile."
She's like, "Yeah, that's gross."
They lied to us.
Crunchyroll, what if I
was allergic to alcohol?
- They gave you free alcohol
and you didn't even know.
- 'Cause there was alcohol
right after in the after-party.
Okay, so we know that you're
now working for Book Walker
and GeeXPlus and all that,
that's really great Meilyne.
- Why say it so condescending?
- Because that's not what
I care about Meilyne,
I wanna know what you were doing
when you were younger in Japan.
What jobs were you doing?
- We wanna know about your week.
- What is your path to
getting to where you are now?
- We want the viewers to recognize
with your shonen protagonist art,
we need to build up Meilyne's character.
- We've told all of our back stories,
it's time for us to tell your back story.
- Backstory? Okay.
So I used to go to a lot
of anime conventions-
- As you do.
- Yes,
and, where am I going with this?
- That's how you met your husband right?
- Yeah, yeah, that's the thing.
I forgot to tell the story
or not tell the story.
I wanted to say like the biggest tip
is to envision what position
you want in the anime industry
and make like steps to get there.
And the steps I made for myself
is one, keep going to a
lot of anime conventions
and make friends that work in some, like-
- In the industry.
- Yeah, yeah.
And one of the people
that I met at a convention
happened to bring Japanese rock bands,
yeah, Japanese rock bands to
the U.S anime conventions.
And then that person introduced
me to a lot of people
that were in Japan and the
hardest thing for a foreigner,
for someone to get there...
No, sorry, the hardest thing
is to get into Japan with the visa.
Finding a job that'll give you a visa
when you don't speak good
Japanese is extremely difficult.
So the first thing I did was get a job
that has no relation to
anime, to get the experience
and then try to do a consulting job
that consults for anime figure,
like, type of companies.
And then, after that, meet
people from that industry,
get the know-how from them
and then apply to the job that I have now.
But, gosh, I'm like-
- Damn, that's calculated.
- Yeah, I calculated everything.
- At the end of the day,
you know, it's that age old,
like, it's not what you
know, it's who you know.
- I think I've heard similar
stories with other friends,
like Nabi, who I had no idea
how he knew so many people
in the industry.
And I remember asking
him and he was just like,
"Yeah, just go to enough events,
just talk to enough people."
- There's a lot of events here.
For me I'm like a nervous wreck.
- Yeah, we could tell. (laughing)
- Do not be fooled by
Meilyne's nervousness,
she is a killer.
(dramatic music)
- It's only you guys in the room,
so that's why I'm comfortable,
but it's like, if there's more than that,
holy, oh my god, this
would be soaked. (laughing)
So like you have to meet people, network.
- And a lot of people will
find that difficult in the U.S
and abroad, 'cause the only
place I could possibly think of
is like conventions and everything.
But in Japan, there are
so many official events
that you can go to to meet people.
What would you recommend then?
Like what should people look out for
if they wanted to just
be in the right place
at the right time?
- There's a lot of
Facebook groups actually,
and a lot of these Facebook groups
are for like the otaku community,
and sometimes they have industry people
as surprise guests or like just show up.
So go to those and you can meet people,
or when there's like,
they're kinda like panels,
industry panels,
you can meet people at the
after party of these things.
- From experience, I've had people,
one thing I know that doesn't work
is to just go up to someone
and being like, "Hey, I'm this person,
here's my business card, call me."
And I'm just like, I don't
know what you do bro.
What do you want to do with me?
- I've had that so much.
They come to you really like
suave, like, "Here's my card,
I expect to hear from you."
- You small talk first though.
- At least explain what is the purpose
of you going up to people, right?
Like, what is the kind of
connection that you want?
It's not just about like,
"I wanna make a connection
because I want a connection."
It's about, why do you
want the connection,
what do you wanna do with the connection
and explain why it'll be
mutually beneficial, right?
They'll just be like, "Here's
my business card, call me."
- If you know that they would
be in a beneficial position
sometimes I might just play dumb
and be like, "Oh yes, what do you do?"
- They'll tell me and I'll be like,
"Oh, no way, I'm in the same industry."
But then they're like,
yeah, that's organic, right?
But the whole time, I'll be like-
(Joey laughing)
- Because a lot of weebs don't realize
that one of the most important
skills you need to learn
when getting a job in any
industry, it's just social skills.
- God-dam it, no!
- Not a lot, you just
gotta learn social skills.
- But I don't wanna talk to people!
- I actually tutored random
people in English, in Japan
to develop social skills.
- And like, it should be
inspiration for all of you.
If this nervous wreck can
develop enough social skills
to be working in the industry
and convince fucking Japanese companies
to form GeeXPlus, there's
hope for you as well, okay?
- No amount of social anxiety
is gonna stop you, alright?
- 'Cause the first time I called you,
I was like, "Wow, why is
she so fucking nervous?"
- On the phone, I think you were like,
"Oh, it's okay, don't be nervous."
And I'm like, "Oh it's just,
it's winter, it's really cold."
'Cause my voice gets shaking.
- That's the worst thing
to say though, right?
- Yeah, and it got me more nervous.
- Saying "Don't be nervous,"
it's just gonna get them more nervous.
- I think I was like,
"Why are you so nervous?"
- Yeah, you said that,
and I was like, "No,
it's cold, it's cold."
- I didn't know that was like-
- That's a no-no.
- I wanted to see what kind of
reaction Meilyne would give,
I don't know why.
I just wanted to see,
'cause I just got a vibe
that you would react really funny.
- We met in real life first,
at the anime expo.
- We did,
that's why I didn't mind.
- And then you said
the same thing, you were like,
"Oh, you don't have to be so awkward."
- 'Cause we were talking
and you're like, "Well, I
don't know if we can, um,"
and I was like, what the fuck's
wrong with you? (laughing)
- Cause I remember my
first business meeting
with you as well and whenever
Meilyne's negotiating,
it's like the most hilarious
thing I've ever seen.
- When we had the piece of paper out,
and I was like, "How about this?"
- I feel like it's so obvious
if you don't like the deal that's offered.
You're like, (humming).
- It's like, "How do I say no
without sounding like an asshole?"
- I know how she says it, she says, "Oh."
When you hear Meilyne saying that,
you're immediately like,
"Oh, it's not good, is it?"
- I was about to say, you can
write a fuckin' dictionary
on your fuckin' ohs, and
like, which tone you say it in
just communicates something
completely different.
- You even type it to us as well.
When I'm texting you about a business deal
and I'm like, "Oh they
came back with this,
what do you think?"
And you legitimately come back with, "Oh,"
and immediately I'm
just like, "Say no more,
I know exactly what you mean."
- I remembered a story, I
don't know if I've told this.
I told you guys about the time
at "Promare" there was a guy?
- No, no.
- So, when I was at the
premier of "Promare",
I was sitting in the Studio Trigger seats
'cause a friend got me into
the Studio Trigger seats
and I was like, well, it's fuckin' cool.
So I'm sitting on the end
of the Studio Trigger seats,
"Promare" is about to start,
and it's obviously Studio Trigger seats
'cause all the seats say
reserved for Studio Trigger.
So I'm sitting there, and this
guy in like a final fantasy
like Claude cosplay comes up to me
and he goes, "Hey do you work at Trigger?"
And I was like, no, these guys do.
He's like, and then I say that to him
and was like, Oh I've made a mistake,
'cause then he's like, "Oh, hello."
And then I'm like, Oh my god."
Over me, he's like, "Hello?"
Bear in mind, he's full
costume, fuckin' giant sword.
He's like, "How do I get
a job at Studio Trigger?"
to this Japanese man who
can't speak a word of English.
And he's like (sound)
- Yeah, you should've just
been like, "Not like this."
- Literally, I was like,
"Bro, I don't think
this is the right time."
He asked that to them,
they were visibly confused,
and I'm like, "Bro, I don't
think this is the right play."
He's like, "Oh, okay."
And I'm like, what The fuck?
- With these kinds of people,
what do they expect the answer to be?
Be like, "Oh yes, here's my
business card, contact me."
- It's like, "You were the right guy.
We were waiting for
someone to be bold enough
to ask us at the 'Promare'."
(laughing) Like, no, fuck off!
- Like no, that's not how you get a job.
- It's just like one of those
moments, I was like, "Oh no."
- That's secondhand embarrassment, right?
- This is the biggest L
I've ever seen in my life.
- So, advice, at your next convention
and you see an industry
guest, don't do that.
That's not how you get a job.
- I couldn't believe it.
- I don't think they're looking to hire
when they're at conventions.
- The person that's
like, the hiring person
wouldn't go to that
event anyways, I think.
- I mean, if I ran an anime company,
the last place I would go to hire people
is the anime convention.
- It just seems like the way to get hired
in Japanese companies it's just
first to be in Japan, right?
- In Japan or like apply to U.S companies,
like Crunchyroll and Viz Media.
- Being outright and so like, not even,
I mean, that's a little
aggressive asking, right?
Like that kind of way, just doesn't work.
It's like, you gotta insert yourself.
- You weren't even cosplaying
as a Trigger character,
you're cosplay is fuckin' Claude.
- So if he turned up full,
like real "Kill la Kill".
- As you can see I am a
fan, can I have a job?
- It's like our audience
knows what we think
about working in Japanese companies.
How has it for you who actually
works in a Japanese company
for the industry?
- I worked in different Japanese companies
before the anime one, awkward mode on.
- It's okay, it won't hurt
you, it's a microphone.
- I don't know, you want me
to say it's like exciting,
it's like nervous.
- No, just be honest.
- Are the rumors true, are
Japanese companies hell?
I'm joking.
'Cause just like black companies, white.
- Yeah, so like, Japan
has like this terminology
where it's like, it's black or it's white.
White is like, they follow the rules,
they treat their employees nice,
and then black is like, they overwork you,
they ask you to work like, I don't know,
12 hours or something like that.
But no, I got really lucky, I think.
The company I work for is
really like very aggressive
about telling their employees,
"Go home, have a social life."
And they highly, highly value that.
- That's good.
- Well, what do you think
about the Japanese like
work-life schedule?
- As someone who lives there.
- I think it's on average Japanese,
they work on average 80 hours a week.
- Yeah.
- Jesus Christ.
- 80 hours a week.
- How was like your work-life schedule
compared to when you are
working outside of Japan,
if you have any comparison.
- Well, I only worked
for an American company
in like San Francisco
for a month before I quit
and chase my anime dreams.
I guess, based on that
one month experience,
it's very different.
Like, in America I would just clock out
and leave that's it,
Here, it's like, you wanna
impress your supervisor
with good results and sometimes
to get those good results,
I mean, it doesn't
necessarily make more time
but if you spend more time
doing more research...
- Meilyne's a hard worker.
- I don't know, maybe.
- On the polar opposite,
you got like the Scandinavian countries
which are like six hours a day is fine,
four days a week, that seems good.
But I mean, there's been plenty of studies
that prove that working more
doesn't necessarily mean more money.
I mean, there's studies to actually prove
the opposite of that,
which is working less
tends to be more productive.
- I mean, that's where
the whole controversy
of the whole thing comes from, right?
Where like employees of
traditional companies
are almost forced, like socially,
it's not a rule in the company,
but they're almost socially
bound to stay back overtime
to work.
- I don't think they should though.
- Not because they need to do the work,
but because as you said,
they wanna impress the supervisors, right?
- Yeah, kind of.
But there are some times,
I think they really shouldn't stay behind
even if they're not really
"working" or working
because it really takes a
toll on their mental health.
Like for me, usually before an event
the month or month and a half,
I'm actually working like really late,
like 11:00 PM or something
because crunch time type of thing.
And I felt like, miserable
during those times,
so I can only imagine how
miserable Japanese people
at Japanese companies that do overtime-
- I feel sorry for them.
- Yeah. I felt angry for no reason.
I'm like, why am I angry?
Oh, it's because, am I working too much?
But I really loved what I did.
Even if you love what you do though,
when you get tired, you get cranky.
- I mean, that's the same as us.
I mean, we love our jobs
but we're always working,
and we never get a break but
even though we love what we do
there's times when I fuckin' hate anime.
You're just like, no.
- There are times where I'm just like,
"I don't wanna work on this video man,
I just wanna play games."
- I know, I know.
- Watch porn or something.
it's like anything else to
just get my mind off of it.
- Two hour porn marathon.
- Just watch it. (laughing)
It's just one of those days, you know?
- What's the convention
time like for you then?
Because for us, it's like,
especially AX is busy as hell
but I've seen people
working in the industry
working fucking overtime when
it comes to convention season.
- I wonder as well, expanding on that is,
how does it all work with
industries and the conventions?
- I can only speak from my
particular perspective or spot.
- I wouldn't expect you to
be the arbiter of knowledge
on conventions. (laughing)
- Japanese companies, I
think they have to prepare
a lot more than U.S companies
because we have to consider
people that don't speak
English coming over
and their first time
exhibiting at an event,
and the amount of time it
takes to ship something.
Like, if they're going to sell something,
at overseas at the convention,
shipping it might be a problem.
So it takes like a lot of time.
- To be fair though,
if I can say something,
I don't know if it's just Kadokawa,
I've noticed with any booth
that is run by a Japanese company,
the amount of staff they
have, it's kinda ridiculous.
- There's usually like a supervisor
that's watching another supervisor
watching other supervisors.
- It's like the entire supply
chain watching each other.
- In American company booths,
maybe it's like two to five max.
The Kadokawa booth had like 60 people.
- I remember going inside
the Kadokawa booth,
I remember there was like 30 employees.
I was like, this is just stupid.
- The reason is, each person,
like, even within Kadokawa,
say these are all from the same series
or no, not the same
series, same publisher,
each department has a
different person in charge
and that person charged
needs to be there to like-
- But this feels like it's been like-
- But do they though?
- This feels like this
should've been like-
- Coordinated, right?
Just get like one person
to just kind of look over everything
and then once the event
is done, just report that.
- Seems like a lot of redundancy.
- I think it's also important
for them to go overseas
because they're like, their mind is open,
you become open-minded?
- Yeah, sometimes.
- It's just like how American otakus are.
- But the problem is, half the employees
don't come out of the booth.
So they don't even get to
experience the culture.
- But they can see, or
hear from outside the booth
like what item's being sold
the most and like take men-
- So what do they think
of foreign conventions
and the foreign culture
then, from your perspective?
- I've heard think it's
like, wow, amazing.
So different and like, so open
compared to the fan otaku culture here.
- That's what I've heard from
a lot of Japanese people.
- The fans here are really uptight.
Like for example, like
Comiket or anime events here,
you can't go there and cosplay
because you would bring
shame to the event.
- Oh yeah, I've heard that story.
- Actually, my friends
and I cosplayed at Comiket
like six years ago,
and we were the top
trending thing at that time
on tuchan, saying "These
three American girls
cosplaying as "Love Live" on the train."
And shame on me for not
doing my research beforehand-
- But still, chill.
- Yeah.
I had like friends in America,
Japanese friends in America messaged me,
"What are you guys doing over there?
You can't cosplay in the train."
- Isn't it fun though?
I'd love to see a cosplay on the train.
- We had like a circle follow
us from station to station.
They were like, "Oh,
can you take that off?"
But we were only wearing the wig.
Like I was wearing normal
clothes, just the wig.
- So you're not even
allowed to wear a wig.
- Yeah, and then my friend told her,
like, "You know, we're
only wearing the wig,"
they're like, "No, they
know from your hair,
what character you are."
- But look, I understand if
it's something gratuitous,
like if you were all
cosplaying as fuckin' Ryuko,
where it's like a little
more like scandalous right?
But like, it's "Love Live",
you're in school uniform.
The only thing that separates
you from a regular school girl
is just the wig.
- But to be fair, they
wanna protect this culture,
they wanna keep having these events.
- It's just gate keeping.
- That is gate keeping.
- For example a normie
would be on the train
and they see some crazy cosplayer.
- Isn't it fun though?
- But also like anime otakus in Japan
aren't viewed in like a positive light.
- I don't think they necessarily
are though in the West.
- I don't feel like
there's as bad a stigma
compared to this here.
- They think you're like
sweaty and I mean, I am,
but like, sweaty (laughing).
You're just so weird,
you watch the weird stuff
on the internet.
- Cosplay's not even that weird.
- I rocked up on the London
underground in a maid outfit.
Like, just did it, just like
40 minute commute, hell yeah.
Everyone loves it,
they're like all laughing,
all giggling and asking questions.
- Were they being like,
"What do you cosplaying
or dressing up as?"
- I get heckled from the
other side of the thing,
and then like, you know,
it's just good fun.
I don't know, I thought it was funny,
but obviously, I guess-
- It's such a weird double
standard though, isn't it?
Where it's like, anime-loving otakus
are like, "Ooh, sweaty, gross."
And then meanwhile, if
there's a guy rocking up
with like full on like,
you know, idols shit,
they're like, "Yeah, he
just really likes idols."
It's like, no, he's just a sweaty.
- A lot of people think it's gross.
Every time I told Japanese people,
like, "Oh, I'm an otaku,"
they're like, "No, you're not,
you don't look like otaku."
What does otaku look like?
And it's like, really, how
dare you insult my people?
- Yeah, like what do they
expect an otaku to look like?
Where it's like, you're
fuckin' 300 pounds.
- I think it's like how the word weeaboo
used to be seen like 10
years ago in our community
where, who would identify
themselves as a weeaboo?
That's like a cringy person
nobody wants to know, right?
- Because the stereotypical
otaku in Japan,
you don't see people like that anymore.
There's people who like anime
and that's just normalized here.
- That was cool.
Like 20 year old girls
have like the Ita-bags,
and love 2d boys.
- And everyone loves JoJo's.
That's like the Chi-Chi, right?
Where you just where JoJo
merch to a business meeting-
- It just feels so good.
- You'll get like a 50
year old businessman
and be like, I love JoJo's.
- I was buying manga,
like my local bookstore,
and I was wearing one
of the glam JoJo shirts,
and a guy stopped putting in the books
and he's like, "Where'd
you get that shirt from?"
And I was like, "Oh, glam."
and he's like, "That looks sick, dude."
He just high fived me, I'm like,
I've never had this experience in Japan.
Obviously this was before the
pandemic, social distance.
- And everyone clapped. (laughing)
- And everyone in the
store applauded Joey.
- And then they played the
JoJo opening and I left.
- JoJo's theme came on.
- As I run out the store.
Yeah, he just straight up high-fived me,
I was like, cool.
Jojo brings people together
man, that's fucking awesome.
- I remember I mentioned in my,
like when I streamed the
dating in Japan video,
I mentioned like, oh yeah,
I just openly said I was an otaku,
and then I was like,
why are people getting
all worked up about it?
And then I've got loads of comments
they're like, "It means
a bad thing in Japan."
I was like, yeah, I
know, I just don't care.
If I can normalize it, I
can help to get there, sure.
- Someone wants to see
it in a negative light,
that's their prerogative.
- Most of the people that I told it to
just didn't give a shit.
- Going back to conventions though,
one thing I've always been curious about
is how would you guys pick
the guests to bring over
and showcase to people?
Is there a process behind that or?
- Yeah, for my company, there was,
at the time when I was like
the person in charge of events.
We would look first at the
sales, like, oh, what's trending,
what's like the top selling manga
or light novels, the top 10,
and then I just contact them, yeah.
And because I'm in Book Walker,
and Book Walker like has really close ties
to all different kinds of publishers,
I guess we're able to ask them.
- That makes sense, 'cause I've
done so many creative panels
especially at AX with Book Walker.
- Like "DanMachi",
"Overlord","Goblin Slayer",
"Monster Musume".
- And I remember every time
one of those panels finish,
it's always one person who
comes up to me for some reason
of all people and it's like,
"Hey, next year can you get
the author of this light novel?
That'd be really cool."
- Did you ever get people who thought
you were the author of something?
- Yeah.
- I've had that as well.
Someone came up to my thing,
this is back when the
93% was still a thing.
Some guy, like a 13 year
old boy came up to me,
and I'm just like, that's weird,
why is there a guy in my line?
- The 7%?
- He comes up to me and
he's like, oh yeah, yeah.
He took a photo, did the signing,
he's like, you're the author
of "Goblin Slayer", right?
No kidding.
I was like, "No."
- Because we had autographs at our booth
for "Goblin Slayer".
- He was like, "You're the
author of 'Goblin Slayer'."
I'm just like, do I look like Japanese?
- I don't get a lot of,
"Oh, you're the author,"
but I always get a lot
of like, "You're the guy
who does the official translation."
It's like because you translated
what the author was saying,
so you must split...
And yeah, I remember I
had a guy just being like,
when's volume three of "Goblin
Slayer" gonna get translated?
Like I fuckin' know.
- You should've just been
like, yeah actually tomorrow.
- I'm working on it right
now actually, don't worry,
it's coming soon.
- If you would've just left me
alone, it would've been done.
- Yeah, I get so many
people just being like,
"Hey, can you bring on this creator?
Or like this author?"
I'm just like, don't ask me
about it, I'm just hosting it.
- The anime departments
of certain companies,
they usually bring guests of
like say directors or whatever
of whatever anime is
coming out that season,
and they have a premiere
and the author or director
comes to promote the premiere.
So not necessarily, it's like trending-
- So it's basically
just all marketing then,
is the way I see it.
It's all data, it's all marketing.
- It's all data and marketing,
it's all businesses.
- 'Cause I always wondered,
AX must be really expensive
to like put up all the booth,
the staff, the marketing.
Is it like, I mean, it obviously
it must be worth it, right?
Like, is the return on
investment huge then?
- I mean, they're not really
looking for sales directly.
- I think it's just looking for presence.
- Brand presence.
- If you don't have presence,
it's like not being at
E3, you know what I mean?
- Guess even companies now are questioning
if E3's worth it.
- I mean, Sony wasn't there
E3 the year before I think,
and that was like massive news
because that was like a massive statement
being like, "Hey, we
don't fuckin' need E3."
- We're fuckin' Sony.
- I wonder if that would
be a thing with that.
Like AX when the company is like,
Oh we don't really need AX anymore.
- A lot of companies
though, Japanese companies
are bringing their own guests
instead of doing the guest of honor thing.
- 'Cause I feel like right now
with like anime growing
so much in the West,
I think there is a big, like
there's more eyes at AX now,
so like, if you're not there,
then that's like a missed
opportunity more than,
"Hey, this is E3, this
is already established."
- There's so much press too,
a lot of news sites are all at this events
so they could arrange interviews
or whatever that could promote it.
- So going back 900 million topics ago,
with how we started it, piracy
and KissAnime going down,
like what are our final thoughts?
What are our like final
thoughts on pirating anime?
'Cause we've thrown around
a bunch of like different
discussions about it.
- This episode's turned into like
an anime industry episode as a whole,
and I think wrapping
up the piracy debates.
- I don't wanna get any companies
that never wanna work with us.
I mean generally, piracy, bad.
I think we can all agree
piracy is not good,
but like everything in life, there is no-
- Sometimes it's a
necessary evil, you know.
- It's not always clear cut
and I think until people in
the positions of authority
most of the time or who in the industry
recognize that there
might be, in some cases,
you know, it's like, whatever.
- It's much of a service problem
as it is a community problem, right?
Because like, yeah, of
course people will say like,
oh you know, the only reason
these piracy sites are thriving
is because these legal
sites aren't doing the job
that these piracy sites are covering.
But then at the same time,
a lot of the community is like, nah, dude
let's just use the piracy stuff.
- I don't think you need to
justify or shame people either.
- No, definitely not.
- And I think there's one thing,
one last point I want to
make about the service thing
where no matter what,
I don't think legal sites
will ever get to a point
when they can fully compete with piracy.
I mean, there's never
going to be one company
that has all the shows or
has every show in existence.
- Even though every company
is trying their best.
- Every company is trying their best,
but I don't think we'll
ever get to a point
where we're going to get
like a legal KissAnime,
know what I mean?
or a legal whatever site.
And I think recognizing that
it is an uneven playing field
and legal companies aren't perfect,
but in my eyes I give
them a bit of leeway.
All I look for is if I can
just play my fuckin' anime
on my Chromecast without any worries,
and that's pretty much all I
need for my $5 subscription.
- Yeah, I've paid for
Crunchyroll for years.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And I just like, if we
could just stop the argument
being like, okay, you are
either on one side or the other
either with us or against us,
I think there's a healthy middle ground
for people to be hard.
- Also, who the fuck
cares? Let's be honest.
I'm gonna pay for it,
and if you don't want to,
I don't particularly care.
I think there's enough people like me
who have disposable income
and can afford to do so
and are willing to do so
that at the end of the day,
who fuckin' cares?
Mostly people who are
like on their high horse,
shouting at people not to pirate,
you're shouting at like 12 year old kids
who don't know any
better, let's be honest.
That's what half of Twitter is.
Who gives a fuck?
I'll just keep paying, I don't care.
- That's like going to the lower class
and being like, you
can't afford Balenciaga?
What the fuck's wrong with you?
It's like, yeah, maybe
some people just can't.
- What do you mean you're
buying knock-off Balenciaga?
- You're not supporting
the fashion industry
because of that.
It's like, yeah, just do you man.
- Like, none of us really
care that much, I don't think.
We're not like activists or whatever.
- If you pay for your anime legally, cool.
You pay for it illegally? Cool.
- My philosophy has and always has been
just do what you can, you know.
Everyone's situation is different,
everyone's got a different reason
or is in a different position in life.
Just do what you can and
do what you feel like.
- Don't be a bully.
- Just don't be a dick.
- Don't be a dick,
and just like, don't try to
take advantage of the system
and yeah, that's pretty much my opinion.
- And please, Konami stop
making Pachinko machines,
I beg of you.
Make anything but Pachinko.
- And checkout Book Walker. (laughing)
That's the bottom line.
Well you know what?
You can also check out Patreon,
like these lovely people have.
- Look at these lovely names on screen.
- They support the show,
do you see them all?
I like him, I like him or her.
- Big thank you to today's
sponsor as well, EJ ANiME STORE.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
Also you can go check out our subreddit,
also check it out Twitter,
all the links as always
is in the description below.
- Monkey-brain gang rise up.
- Unfortunately I don't think
you can check out Meilyne,
do you have any social
media you want to shout out
or anything, Meilyne?
- It's cringy, so no.
- But again, you can
check out Book Walker,
- Check out Book Walker instead.
Do you run the Twitter
account for that still?
- No, I stopped like
last year or something.
- That's why the memes became less fire.
- The last thing I posted
was inter-species reviewers.
- Wow.
- Thank you very much
for coming on Meilyne.
I know there was a lot of limited things
you could not talk about,
especially still working on the industry,
but we very much appreciate you.
- That's business, man.
- I'm sure people will be mad
that you didn't get to talk as much as us,
but you know, we talk our asses off.
- If I talk too much, I
might say something illegal.
Just kidding. (laughing)
- If you guys want more
Meilyne, don't worry,
there'll be plenty of Meilyne,
us shouting at Meilyne.
- She'll always be behind
there somewhere, you know.
Behind the camera, the secret
mastermind behind this show.
- Thank you very much for coming on
and shining more light on the industry.
- Thank you for having me.
- Saying what you can say
about what goes on behind the scenes.
'Cause I know there's a lot of eyes
and you don't wanna get
fired or anything like that.
- I think a lot of people that
will appreciate your opinions
especially with the whole
like getting a job in Japan.
- Yeah, check out Craigslist.
- Shout out to Craigslist.
- Shout out to Craigslist, except-
- Craigslist doesn't even
sponsor people, I think.
- Hey, hey Craigslist.
- Except when there are
cockroaches in the fridge.
- No, I've seen too much,
you should not be supporting this.
- Craigslist gave you
your visa. (laughing)
- Anyway, thank you very
much for watching today.
We've been "Trash Taste" and the boys
and Meilyne's been there,
and we'll see you guys next time.
- Bye.
(ambient music)